today we're going to go through as many
of your lessons as we can in about three
hours and we're going to see what we can
get through first one
a friendly reminder that in three
generations everyone who knew us will be
dead including the people whose opinions
stopped you from doing what you wanted
all along imagine that someone you know
achieves every dream and hits every goal
they have years later they get old and
die two years after that how much do you
care about as much as everyone else will
if you accomplish your goals and dreams
do it for you
so I think about death all the time
because it's probably the central theme
it's probably the thing that I think the
most about and I think that influences
how I see time and also how I think how
how it influences agency like what
actions I'm willing to take despite the
Judgment of others and so a lot of times
it might be because I have more
insecurity than everyone that I think
like man I want to do this thing and
then I hear all these other voices of
reasons why I shouldn't do it or why
somebody else will say like that's bad
or yield bad or like that's wrong
whatever
and so I think I've had to come up with
a lot of these devices to get around my
own insecurities to take action despite
those insecurities and the biggest one
that I think about is that
it doesn't matter whether I achieve all
of my goals or I don't achieve all of
the goals in three generations I'll be
forgotten and the only people who were
nacing against me will also be dead
and so then it's like
just do it for me and then
when I wake up every day
there's only one voice I have to listen
to
but that means that you need to be able
to work out what to do from first
principles you now no longer have
societal Norms or assistance or Role
Models or archetypes or expectations and
that's also difficult in a different way
I think that the more you Flex whatever
that muscle is of like independent
thinking the more it becomes the default
way that you think and then everyone
else's action is to start looking more
and more insane to you
what like what's an example of that that
you can think of
I mean shoot
just the most basic ones of like living
the life that you don't want not wearing
what you want to wear not dating who you
want to date not living where you want
to live like you're living at home and
you want to move and your parents say no
and you don't make the move or you're
digging a girl because she's socially
accepted you know by your friend group
she's safe but like there's always some
distance in between you but you're like
I don't want to risk it right or like
you're in the the job and every day you
go there and you're like I mean it's
okay and the idea of just living an okay
life just sounds so terrifying to me
that the freedom to fail over and over
again is still more fulfilling to me at
least it feels like it's real
then walking through kind of on
autopilot and so I think that's a lot of
the choices that other people make that
seem insane to me now but didn't didn't
seem insane to me a decade ago you know
what I mean I think it's just like as
you practice
taking more agency taking more
responsibility for the decisions then
you just get better and better at it and
then it just seems more and more
ridiculous you're like they're like I
just can't quit my job and you're like
why
like no physically why like why can't
you quit your job like like you know I
mean they start hyperventilating it's
like you could could you move in with
your parents could you move in with a
friend could you split rent I mean I
could but I mean
other people who are going to die in a
hundred years would think what
and one of my favorite ones is um
and I say this all the time to Layla
like whenever we're getting to some sort
of like mini complaint it's like you
know if you zoom out far enough you
can't see the Earth so we're talking
about like oh man they're gonna mess up
this order on this vendors like you know
if you zoom out far enough you can't see
the Earth
it's just like it just puts everything
immediately into perspective of how
ridiculous some of the things that we're
concerned about are
Sean puri's got this thing where he says
don't follow what most people do because
you don't want the results that most
people get the average person is obese
likely to be divorced and has less than
1K in the bank it feels safe to do what
everyone else is doing but it's actually
a terrible decision
it's like the best way to guarantee to
not have the life that you want is to do
what everyone else is doing
unless you want what everyone else has
with no one which no one does
yeah it's um
being able to
think for yourself and and treating it
like a muscle I think is a smart way to
consider it because in the beginning
it's really really hard you've been
resting on societal norms and the way
you've dealt with past trauma and your
parents expectations and what all of
your friends do and what's accepted and
all of this stuff for so long
that when it first comes to you needing
to step on that muscle it's like trying
to move your ears like all humans have
got muscles that can move their ears but
because no one works it as a child
they're just atrophy away uh and this is
the ear muscle of personal growth
I think I had a lot of practice with it
because I had a so like a lot of people
have many voices that they hear that
they feel are judging them right they
have their friends they have their uncle
they have their siblings they have their
cousins co-workers whatever I think I
had just one voice that I heard really
loudly and I was trying I was talking to
one of our one of our employees the
other day and I was trying to put it in
perspective younger guy and I was like
I imagine how much you care about your
mother's opinion and your father's
opinion and your ship and all of those
other people I was like and now imagine
that there's literally only one because
I had no siblings I basically had no
mother
I had just a father
and so like his approval was literally
everything and he disapproved of the
path that I wanted to take in my life
and so I think a lot of these mental
faculties are these little Frameworks or
these isms just came from like
how can I combat this incredibly booming
voice in the background because like
when I look at what I was doing at the
time like I was a consultant you know I
graduated in three years I took the
consulting job I did all the things but
the craziest thing was that the moment
that my father was most proud of me and
he approved of my life the most was when
I was the saddest
and so that's when I was like maybe his
approval isn't the right way to feel
good about life
and so that that started basically the
six month journey of from when I decided
that I wanted to change my life until
when I changed it and I think that like
as you become more able or more potent
or higher agency that timeline between
when you decide you want to do something
and when you actually do it just
continues to compress right like now if
I want to change something I'm like
let's change it like done I like I we
walk out of the things like we're never
gonna do that podcast together I don't
want to talk to this person again or
whatever it is right whereas before it's
like
okay I have to sleep on it I have to
really think about it and like how am I
gonna it's like why do I care about how
I'm gonna say it this is what it is done
and it's just like that timeline is
compressed but the hardest one for me
like the first one was by far the
hardest and everyone since then the nice
thing is that no matter how difficult
your circumstance is if you have like
the bigger the wall that you have to get
through is as soon as you get past that
one big wall you then can use that wall
as the evidence for why you can jump
over the next well because that will be
the biggest one and so like after I did
quit my job and left my house and and
left Baltimore and didn't tell my dad
until I was across the country because I
was so afraid like people think of me as
like some big Alpha whatever dude I was
like I was such I was so afraid of my
father's disapproval that I didn't tell
him until I physically left the state
like like I'm not like think about that
like I wasn't even just one state over I
was like five states over and then I was
like hey by the way I'm going to
California and he was like well let's
come over we'll talk about it and I was
like I'm in Ohio already yeah yeah all
right you know then obviously he had a
different reaction but like but then
after that it was like what do I have to
do now it's like oh I gotta I gotta sell
strangers and I was like I told my dad I
didn't want to do what he wanted how
hard could this be
and so like it then becomes this one
huge proof point so the bigger the the
dragon is that you have to slay the more
evidence you have that you can say the
next dragon and I think that is if
there's ever been a good point for why
getting over the one first hard one is
so hard is that it will then give you
the reinforcement that you can do
whatever you need to do next yeah the
life you want is on the other side of a
few hard conversations and you're living
a life you hate because you're too
afraid to have them
I think about that a lot
because like whenever I feel anxious or
insecure or angry or sad I'm like what
conversation do I need to have that I'm
not having
and so then and usually if I just think
for not that long I'm like this is the
conversation I've been putting off and
then you know I'm not the the the the
poster child of mental health and so um
I'll just call myself a pansy for not
having the conversation and then and
then I just have it and so again I think
it's like I need to have this
conversation and the time between when I
have it versus or when I when I know I
need to have it when I actually have it
just because it continues to compress
and if you've ever had like a a breakup
or a employee firing one of the or
acquitting if you're an employee like
these things that you dread
I don't know if you notice it but like
the day you do it the moment after you
do it I'm like how many other
conversations can I have like I want to
be like
yeah totally because it's a serial
killer for awkward conversations when I
so like the next series of hard
conversations that I had after I I left
home was actually like years later so I
had I had multiple partners in what I
said I had a I had a partner in one of
my gyms I had a partner in four other
gyms I had a partner in a Cairo and
dental marketing agency and all of them
relied on me to make money
and so all of their livelihoods were
still dependent on me but I was
splitting everything and it was just it
was it was horrible for me at the time
and so I remember when I I ended up
getting in a DUI and you know I talked
to a a performance coach or whatever
and he was like your stress in these
conversations could literally kill you
he's like they almost did so I got a
head-on collision at 60 miles an hour
and I walked away no injuries
um but it was like my wake-up call but
not to stop drinking it was my wake-up
call that I needed to have these
conversations and that's what I was
avoiding when I was drinking it was in
the alcohols what were the things that
I'm avoiding that I'm using alcohol to
get away from and so
um the next day I had the first
conversation with the first partner and
it was horrible but the moment I was
done I was like I gotta call the other
guy and I called the other one I was
like this is how it is and the thing is
is I had this backstop of my death
of like you almost just died because you
wouldn't have this conversation and so
then it just gave me this courage to
just be like like and whatever the
reaction was I was like I'd rather be
alive
I think that was it and so it's it's
weird though because death has been this
really recurring theme in my life that
like
the same thing happened when I was it
like the only thing that gave me enough
balls to stand up to my dad to be fair
from a distance from the car when I was
driving halfway across the country like
let's not make one let's not make me too
big of her out here
um was the idea that like I started
thinking like every day I was like I
hope I don't wake up you know what I
mean
um and that was the that was that was
the thing where I was like this is a big
enough problem that like if you don't
want to wake up then
what have you got to lose
exactly and that was it and I was like I
have nothing to lose and that was when
that was when I think in the last
podcast we talked about this where it's
like if everybody who's like at the
bottom and feels like they have nothing
going for them
reframe that as I have nothing going for
me which also means that I have nothing
to lose by taking action it makes you a
much more dangerous person and I think
that was the flip that I've had
repeatedly shown to me in my life that
allowed me to take the step that I was
afraid to take if I told you about the
region beta Paradox have you seen that
one okay so this is interesting so
imagine that you had to go a mile or
less and if you did a mile a mile okay
if you had to travel a mile or less you
would
walk it and if you had to go more than a
mile you would drive it okay so
paradoxically you would go two miles
quicker than you would go one mile
uh-huh
if you follow that rule the important
Insight here is that if you only take
action when things cross a certain
threshold of Badness sometimes better
things can feel worse than worse things
oh yeah so if you look around and you
see that people are stuck in region beta
this zone of comfortable complacency
right it's the guy that sticks and it's
just okay job because his boss isn't too
much of a dick but the pay isn't that
good and he's not really that passionate
but it's all right whatever whatever the
person that stays in the acceptable
relationship they're not that fired up
but they're not really in love and their
partner's not really got much alignment
with their interests or the person that
stays in a crappy apartment and there's
a bit of mold in the ceiling but it's
cheap and it's in a good area of town or
whatever all of these people would be
better off if their situations were
worse yeah because it would give them
the activation energy to kick them out
of the bottom and their only regret
would be not doing it sooner
did I love that
when I it was funny because if I look
back on the instances that were the most
painful in my life
every single one of them without fail
has created a disproportionate gain
right like the most painful thing early
on was for me was quitting my job and
leaving you know leaving my dad
basically and then that created
the you know my first my first business
in the gyms and all of that stuff
um you know getting into the DUI the
head-on collision
um and like that whole situation got me
out of all of these failed Partnerships
that I wasn't willing to do but in the
in the moment I was like I'm such a
failure like I suck at everything but
that gave me the springboard when I lost
everything the first time after that
um
that then gave me like the idea that I
needed to change the business model
around right and that's what switched me
into the licensing model right so like
each of these time and then that became
you know the the first this is kind of
like Alchemy yeah like turning something
which is worse than useless yeah into
something that's as precious and useful
as possible
you know I'm sure you know the parable
of the you know the man in the Sun and
he like buys the son a horse and then it
falls he breaks the leg and then they're
like oh it's so sad and then the Army
comes then the sun doesn't die and then
it's like oh so great right and so it's
one of those really interesting ones
where like whatever negative situation
and this is probably good for the
audience but like if you think back to
all the negative situations you had like
the really really bad ones when you
expand the time Horizon most times they
become net wins
and so then it just means that like if
you're in a really tough time right now
you just gotta wait
and then you get and then you'll get
your reference point back on all the
things that change those result because
most times when is bad it can't get
worse so then you feel like Well it
can't get worse than this and then your
action threshold decreases and you take
and you do all the things you know you
should have done anyways and so it's
like we have this big stack of should
do's and we just wait until it's two
miles yep and then you just you're like
you're just getting in the car like the
firing conversation and you're like well
I just fired one person or like I just
ended one partnership I just broke up
with one girl or whatever it is and
you're like who else do I need to talk
to today really like and then in like a
period like you have these rapid periods
of growth that happen and then you have
the next web of comfort because it's way
better than you were before and I think
it's I wonder this um this is more just
like an open thought but like I wonder
how long
like more successful people
stay in that next Plateau like I wonder
if their threshold for Action stays low
yeah they're immediate like oh like I'm
getting Comfort like how quickly they
get comfortable into like I need to
change I need to get better um
next one the heaviest things in life
aren't iron and gold but unmade
decisions the reason you are stressed is
that you have decisions to make and
you're not making them
it's a good quote excited you said it
I think a lot of times the decisions
that we make are predicated on the on
the conversations we need to have
because usually like that and what's
interesting is like
you can Define commitment by eliminating
alternatives
so if you're committed you've eliminated
alternative actions right like you can
say I'm committed but until you
eliminate other options you're not
committed there's always a get out of
jail frequently right and so
a lot of people make decisions to end
relationships to quit their job to start
the new thing
but they don't become committed to the
decision until they remove the other
options and then you're forced to take
action on it and so I think actually
defining those two two different things
now you could Define you know decision
is to kill off like decadere from Latin
but from a from an from a colloquial
thing I think there are two different
instances it's like I need to change
this and then I do change it
um
and the making the decision is when it
becomes a commitment why are unmade
decisions so heavy
I think at least for me
it's because I have this hamster wheel
on the my back of my mind where I keep
playing out different scenarios and so I
keep thinking like well maybe maybe I
need to change what I'm currently doing
maybe maybe if I just rethought like
because I'm I'm a big frame guy so I'm
like maybe I just need to be thinking
about this differently right maybe if I
zoom all the way out the Earth doesn't
exist maybe this doesn't matter or maybe
I'm just making a problem that doesn't
exist maybe the best action I should
take is nothing right like I you know I
reframe all those things
um but usually it's just because I'm
afraid of something and then that's why
I'm not making the decision and I think
once I name and put a face and it's
usually not even a thing that I'm afraid
of it's one person's judgment I'm afraid
of and then when I name the person then
it becomes then it becomes real instead
of being this amorphous like people
Society judgment it's like Tom like do I
really care what Tom thinks I guess so
it seems like I'm not making this big
change in my life because of Tom looks
like Tom's more in control of my life
than I am dude so
I remember this
when I was 19 years old I was super
angry like all 19 year old men right
that's the standard default right I was
angry at both my parents for who because
I was 19. right and I remember blaming
them for everything blaming them for my
life blaming for not being a better
person I literally blame them for being
a bad person
and I remember realizing that when I
blamed them that I gave them control
over my life and then the idea that the
people that I hated the most at the time
were the ones who actually were
controlling me was the thing that most
sickened me to then actually flip my
narrative to actually taking control
like that was the one thought process
like my mother I'm giving her control
over my romantic relief like my mother
controls this that I was like
no and so like just the idea that
somebody who I was disgusted by at the
time
um had that much power is what gave me
the power to start taking action see
this hamster wheel thing that continues
to distract you I've got this concept
called anxiety cost so kind of like
opportunity cost yeah
um when you have an unmade decision
every single second that you spend
thinking about the unmade decision could
have been gotten back had you just made
the decision
and realizing that it's it's a
justification for eating frogs earlier
in the day I need to answer that email
the longer that you wait until you
answer that email the more times you
will think the thought I need to answer
that email yeah and if we assume that
what truly truly matters in life is the
time and the attention that we spend
within that time
your time is being captured and your
attention is being captured by a thought
that could have been gotten rid of had
you have just done it had you have just
had the conversation broken up with the
relationship left the job told the
father whatever
done your stretches cleaned your teeth
had a shower whatever it is that you
needed to do
all of that anxiety cost could have been
gotten rid of had you just gone and done
it
you can move through life at seven times
the rate of other people by simply
changing when you say you're going to
make a decision from end of week to end
of day
so think about how that Stacks up so
it's like let's say that there were four
decisions that you needed to make if the
normal person takes a week to make the
decision and then their mind moves on to
the next thing that they have anxiety
for and start making that decision and
decide another week decide another week
decide another week it's a month to make
those four decisions whereas the the
super the Superman the
takes one decision day one one to six
second decision day two third decision
day three fourth decision day four they
aren't even finished the week yet and
they're where the other person is at the
end of the month and like that speed of
decision making like not paying the
attention cost the opportunity cost of
your time
I think it's really profound in terms of
how quickly people move through life in
terms of achieving the goals that they
set out because people were like how did
how is that guy so young and he's
achieved X Y and Z it's like well what
takes you a month to make a decision
we make in an hour and then the next
hour I make another decision that takes
a year next month and so like that's how
you can go 30 times or 100 times faster
than than the quote average person who's
overweight has a thousand dollars in
their bank account you know and it's
gonna die at 70. can you just go back to
before you made that first decision with
your dad because you've mentioned it you
know people might look at your I would
say ruthlessness at least in some
regards with decision making you know
hiring and firing and making these
business decisions and there's all of
these great stories about and I had this
thing and I realized that partner wasn't
right so I got rid of that business and
you know that's the sort of thing that
would tear most people up for six months
18 months maybe forever yeah and to look
at that degree of cut throatness or at
least um decisiveness I think is
almost unfathomable for a lot of people
are you a representative Avatar is pre
leaving Baltimore Alex a representative
avatar for the average person I think so
I mean I was high achieving you know I
mean like I did well in school I tried
hard I did those things but in terms of
my risk tolerance and my fear of failure
and my insecurities yeah absolutely I
mean if anything real talk I bet you
that I have more insecurities than most
people because those insecurities are
what drove me to do well in those things
not because I cared about school but
because I cared about what other people
thought about me yeah yeah I um I've
spoken to
hundreds hundreds and hundreds of high
performers
on balance people are driven way more by
fear of insufficiency than they are with
some well-balanced perfect desire to
just maximize their greatness in life
like the activation energy for almost
everybody is
I'm scared I might be a piece of
what
hang on oh God I might be a piece of
I genuinely might be a piece of
I need to go and do something so
outrageous that I I can't be a piece of
there's no way that it could happen
I might be a coward oh my God what can I
do to stop myself from being a coward
that's the activation energy
it's funny because if you regress fear
to its most basic form it's death
and death is the greatest motivator and
like you can prove it in a simple
example it's like if I all of a sudden
go up to anybody on the street and I put
a gun in their head and I say you know
point a gun at their head and I say go
do this thing they'll go do it
but if I say you can have anything you
want
if you do this they're willing to go 10
times harder
with a gun in their face to not die and
so if you take fear and regress it all
the way down to its basis form like
that's what the insecurity is like if
they they think I won't be enough and if
they don't think I won't be enough then
this won't happen if this one happened
this one happened I'll be alone I'll be
dead I feel like if you just regress it
all the way down like that's all it is
and so like the biggest Achievers in
life I think have have most directly
tied them not doing whatever it is that
they want to do to death
if whether they're consciously aware of
it or not and then that's what motivates
them harder we'll get back to talking to
Alex in one minute but first I need to
tell you about element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
and it's how I've started my morning
every single day for over three years
you do not need to have coffee first
thing in the morning because you're
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't even active but your adrenal
system is and salt acts on your adrenal
system element contains a signed backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium potassium
and magnesium that helps to regulate
appetite curb cravings and improve your
brain function but best of all tastes
phenomenal this orange salt is
unbelievable in a cold glass of water
first thing in the morning and they have
a no BS no questions asked refund policy
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll give you your money back and you
don't even need to return the box that's
how confident they are that you'll love
it head to drink lmnt.com modern wisdom
to get a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom you're not afraid of
failing you're afraid of what other
people will think of you if you fail but
if you're afraid of that imagine what
they think of you when you aren't even
trying
oh yeah they aren't
such a dick sometimes
um does it is it strange to hear that
you're like Angry toilet tweets
read back to you now in the cold harsh
light of day
oh my God that was a particularly
difficult poo I was cracking
a real talk the the tweets that I have
people don't know this but the tweets
are notes to self yeah so they're just
erected at me so that I can look back on
them and like be reminders of like hey
don't don't do that and so like I think
to myself man I'm afraid of doing this
and I'm like no I'm not I'm afraid of
what this person's gonna think about me
because if I were to be able to fail
in quiet and complete isolation then I
wouldn't care
and then I think well what if I what if
I what if I don't succeed in public what
do they think then nothing right they
don't think about me at all and so
obviously that comes from the
perspective of uh seeking to gain
approval and attention from others
anyway so it's like listen if you're
insecure which everybody is let's be
real
um you might as well use the insecurity
to get something out of it right like
one of my one of my favorite things
about entrepreneurship is like use what
you've got and so a lot of people think
that they need to fix their conditions
in in order to get like the perfect
conditions before they start but the
perfect condition is whatever one you're
in because it gives you whatever assets
you have that's the cards that you're
dealt and so it's you just play the hand
and a lot of people have great cards
it's like man I'm so afraid it's like
use it it's like I have nothing what
makes you very dangerous because you
have nothing to lose right like one of
the um really interesting things about I
think about from a business perspective
but it probably applies to everything is
that there's always an advantage and a
disadvantage from every position right
so like I remember one
I mean Jim March is still a big company
and still continues to grow but in the
gym licensing space there's not many
people who can compete with us there
right and I would talk to guys who are
in the space you know talk you know
talking to conference whatever and you
know younger guys would be like well I
wanna I wanna be in this space too and
it's not fair because you know you have
this big advantage and I was like you
have a way bigger Advantage than I do I
was like because if I were in your
position I would go to every single gym
owner and be like you don't want to be
with Jim launch you want to be with Alex
you're just a number to him like you're
never going to talk to him like you're
just a cog in the wheel there with me
you're going to get my personalized
attention there he's just some employee
down the chain that's following some
process right I was like but on the flip
side if I'm talking to that same gym
owner then I'm going to say you don't
want to talk to Jimmy he lives in his
mom basement he has no proof that he's
good at what he's what he's had the
reason that we're number one in the
space is because we've done it so many
times and we have a system that we know
that if you go on this side you will get
this result on the outside I was like
there's always a position and there's
always an advantage also you just have
to play the one you've got and most
people just look at what everyone else's
advantages and don't think which one do
I have
when you're talking about it's not you
that's afraid of failing yeah you're
afraid of other people's opinions about
why you're going to fail like the reason
I think that cynicism is so popular on
the Internet is that the upside of never
trying is never having to feel the pain
of failure that's fundamental it's sour
grapes at an existential level right it
is a cynicism safety blanket it is
protecting you from ever having to feel
the downside of anything I will assure
my own failure in private so that I
never have to face my failure in public
it's kind of like investing like
everyone's afraid of losing money when
they invest but the only guaranteed
investment that doesn't work is never
investing to begin with
and so it's like they take the long
failure rather than the short one
right I mean it's what it is right you
just fail long
and they're like I prefer that
um that's I mean that's yeah I
it's it's like you and I are going back
and forth on trying to figure out how
many different ways can I say that
either the people that you're worried
about judgment are gonna die or that
you're gonna die or that even if you do
achieve the thing they won't care
anyways or if you don't do anything they
won't think about you to begin with and
don't you want to be thought about to
begin with like don't you want some
level of significance
foreign
I just
you're gonna die
and I think like I was very grateful
that so one of my biggest Inspirations
or whatever you know influences when I
was in Baltimore was I would have lunch
with my grandfather three times a week
so he was 90. old guy so I'll go to the
nursing home and we'd have lunch three
days a week
and listening to him talk about the
regrets that you had in life
it's so much more
painful to watch someone who has no
options left like he's gonna die it
means you die tomorrow and he died a
couple years later I mean like and he
lost all his mental faculties
you know almost sadly basically when I
stopped when I left Baltimore one of the
sad parts is I was one of the only
people that kind of like kept him Lucid
you know what I mean and after that no
one really no one really visited him no
one really did anything and so I think
he he just rolled down I think the
lunches might have been the only thing
that he looked forward to and um seeing
someone old
with no options and nothing but regret
now not that he had everything regret he
had things that he did really well and I
took those things from him
um
he would he would repeat the same
lessons you know like every lunch this
would be where a lot of older people
kind of repeat a few key lessons and
everything that he had he flew during
and he fled during the um during the
World War II uh you know he fled from
the Germans and all that stuff because
he had a Jewish sounding last name
um he wasn't but he it was enough that
he was fleeing right
um and he always used to say he's like
you have two hands and one brain I was
like use them there was always this
thing they said to me and um
I think just like when I would think
about the things that he was going up
against compared to the things that
we're going up against now it just made
me feel like all right like this is not
as big of a deal as I really think it is
I don't have Germans at the at my door
what were the regrets that you had him
yeah
he would have spent I mean again there's
deathbed regrets and then there's real
life regrets but there's there's things
that he would have done differently in
terms of the business there's things he
would have done differently with his
wife he had he got divorced um that you
know uh he would have done things very
differently with his kids so my mother
um and her sisters
um which actually talking to him about
how he raised my mother
helped me in some way forgive her for
some of the things that I felt were
wrongdoings that she had done to me
and so
it's funny because you know one of my
favorite quotes from Blaise Pascal is to
understand is to forgive and like when
you when you I think there's another
saying that I like a lot which is it's
really hard to hate close up
it's like if you really see someone and
you see all the things that they went
through and the things that they that
happen to them to become who they are
then you understand them and then you
understand why they did X Y and Z
because if we don't understand we assume
that it's because they're just evil
people and most people aren't that way
they're this way because they've been
reinforced or punished for doing
something like that in the past and
especially for her she was reinforced
for acting a certain way over and over
and over again to the point that it was
it was core to her character and so when
that got put on me I was like I hate you
you're terrible you're evil like blah
but like when I looked at it on much
longer time rising of like she was four
years old when she came here she
couldn't speak English she got beat up
as a kid like all these things I'm like
you know what
maybe give her a little Grace you know
and I remember when when I came back and
it was right around that same time where
I realized I was giving this person all
this power
she yelled at me for something when I
came back home from college my freshman
year it was a standard fight you know
here's the button that I press to get
into the normal fight that we get into
um I just remember she hit the button I
just like wasn't that upset and it's
like I felt nothing she like hit the
button she like hit it again harder and
I was like and I just remember looking
at her and being like I get it I'm sorry
like you had a tough tough life
and then she just broke down and you
know started crying because it was like
she felt understood and I think um
I know that was a roundabout way of
getting back to regrets but he regretted
how he had raised her but his through
his regrets I got to see why she was the
way she was and then it defused the bomb
that was between me and her
did I tell you that story Douglas Murray
told me about regrets from Christopher
Hitchens brilliant so
Christopher Hitchens one of the new
atheists uh was sat in some British pub
with Douglas Murray when Douglas is
Young and did that you know you can
imagine it's some musty Chesterfield
sofa he's probably got a cigarette in
his mouth and it's a glass of scotch or
something and uh Douglas is vacillating
between these two different choices that
he needs to make and he is
um complaining implementing the fact
that I have this thing but I have this
thing and if I do this thing I can't do
this thing and and what do I do and
apparently hitch like sat back and
foreign
we must choose our regrets hmm
and I was like so I'm
three Manhattans deep in Douglas
Murray's apartment in Manhattan at two
in the morning and he sneaks off to the
toilet and I quickly write this down
because I know that my like half cut
alcohol brain isn't gonna remember it so
I've known it down because that was all
the trigger that I needed which is also
a good argument for noting things down
and I reflect I must reflected on that
for a year I must have thought about it
for a year in life we must choose our
regrets what the does that mean
okay first off
in an existence where opportunity cost
is baked in because you don't get to
split test life and by doing a thing you
can't do a different thing I have the
chosen going to the gym and going to the
theme park if I go to the gym therefore
I can't go to the theme park even if the
decision of going to the gym was the
right call
I will always have the open loop of yeah
but what if I'd gone to the theme park
you can't ever know right okay so that
means that fundamentally
regrets are baked in to our existence
and I'd always thought that the reason I
had a regret
was due to some sub-optimal decision I'd
made if only I'd made this decision
better I could have ameliorated the
regret okay so regrets are an
unavoidable part of being a human and
they're a byproduct of opportunity cost
which you can't get away from but what
does it mean that you have to choose
your regrets okay
well if regrets are inevitable if
they're going to happen no matter what
an easy way to look at the decision is
rather than which do I want to do which
regret could I live with
because there are certain regrets that
you can't bear living with now you can
bear living with them but they're going
to be worse than other ones yeah so what
is the difference between I need to have
a difficult decision I need to have a
difficult conversation with my boss
about leaving to go and do this thing or
I need to that's the regret that's one
regret of the sitting down and seeing
them face to face and telling you're
going to leave their small mom and pop
business and you're the main sales
person and it's going to be terrible and
they're going to cry and you're going to
feel like a piece of that's one
regret another regret is looking back at
a decade that you waste in a job that
you hate yeah
so in life you have to choose your
regrets
I love that as a decision making frame
because it also jump starts our
fear engine
because rather than saying like what do
I want it's what I what do I hate least
and so we get to run it so then you get
to use your run away from engine rather
than you go towards doing yeah the right
Mouse and the cheese again yeah and was
it you telling me that uh with a cat I
mean yeah
so I'm just going to butcher what you
told me
um but why don't you share the like how
much yeah yeah this was on our last
episode so this is the sequel for the
people that were listening
um John Peterson talks about the study
where they starve a rat and they put it
into a tube
they waft the smell of cheese in from
the front and there's a spring attached
to the rat's tail so they can work out
how hard it's pulling how hard it's
pulling is a proxy for design for how
much it wants it you'd think this rat is
starving it's going to pull as hard as
it can so it whopped the smell of cheese
in and it runs towards it and whatever
they do another iteration of the study
this time they waft the smell of cheese
in from the front and the smell of a cat
in from behind yeah it pulls harder yeah
why because not only in life do you want
to run towards something you want but
you want to run away from something that
you fear and this ties into your the
three most common traits of very
successful people superiority complex uh
massive crippling insufficiency yeah and
impulse control so superiority complex I
can achieve this thing that's the cheese
um crippling sense of insufficiency I
fear the cat impulse control I'm in a
tube I mean there's only one direction I
can go I don't need to make a choice yep
I love this a lot as a frame for for
decision making because
that like think about the decision that
we were just talking about right so it's
like I'm I'm the sales guy and I stay
and like if you were to frame it in
upsides it's like upside is I keep these
friends right
um
and but I want to leave so that I can
start this business right those are the
upsides but when you think about it in
terms of like I wasted decade of my life
not living the life I want to me I mean
even when I say it it sounds more
motivating even though it's the exact
same thing it's like losing a hundred
dollars versus gaining a hundred dollars
people have three times higher loss
aversion and so it's like if you can't
get yourself to do something think about
it from the perspective of what you have
to lose rather than what you have to
gain you've got a quote that I love my
biggest fear is getting to the end of my
life and thinking I wasn't good enough
what's that mean
and I'll Define good enough is I could
have tried harder
like I want to leave everything on the
field
and one of the things that has helped me
a lot I mean in the quote that went
unbelievably viral
um
do you want me to do it again do I need
to do it again
you don't gain confidence by saying
shouting affirmations in the mirror but
by stacking giving yourself a stack of
undeniable proof that you are who you
say are outwork yourself doubt and again
a lot of the tweets that I have are
notes to self
because like like I have a you know I
have a big presentation coming up we've
got 500 000 people who are registered
for this book launch that are coming out
and I'm thinking to myself as like how
can I guarantee that when I step off
stage no matter what happens I feel like
I've accomplished that I've done a good
job that I can look at myself in the
mirror and say good work
and when I was younger I used to have no
way to do that that's because I measured
everything on outcomes but I feel like
I've got a little bit more experience I
do have a way to win now but it's hard
and the way that I win is when I finish
and I say that there's nothing else I
could have done
and so that means that like the reason
that I feel confident about this book
that's coming out is I wrote 19 drafts
of the book four full rewrites end to
end to make the book I did six hours a
day my first six hours from 6am till
noon every day for two years to get this
book to where it is now and when I was
done with the book I was like there's
nothing else I can do to this like this
is it there's nothing else like I can't
make it simpler I can't make it shorter
I can't cut it I can't add a visual that
I should have added it's done and sort
of the same degree with the presentation
that I have I gave myself this framework
of like okay well if I were to speak in
front of 10 000 people I would probably
spend a good amount of time prepping the
presentation to make sure it was good I
was like why am I speak in front of 500
000. I was like so I can I can
rationalize spending 50 times the amount
of work and effort and time to make this
thing exceptional because I mean the
numbers are hard to Fathom but that is
the numbers like if I had a ten thousand
that's what I would do and so it allowed
me to take a presentation and you know I
have 900 slides that I'm going to get
through in 60 minutes
and I have now every single day I do a
full draft
of the you know I I I'd say that say the
presentation of my head and then I do a
second run where I say it out loud and I
record it and then after I record it I
play the recording with the slides up
and I fix or add every slide where I
Stumble or there's something that should
be there or Visual and I keep going
until now right now I'm a week and
change out and there's there's not much
else I can do to it and so I'll still
continue to do that from now until the
day that it happens but I probably won't
have as many changes because I should
just keep nailing it and then when I get
up there
it doesn't matter if the tech doesn't
work or if the you know the the book
shopping page cart you know doesn't you
know doesn't work or whatever it is
because I'll be able to step off stage
and look in the mirror and be like
you did everything you could and the
thing is is like no one else will know
that because I know that like I could
not do that and I probably like you know
a lot of people were like dude you have
so much good will you could probably
just say like cares you know here's the
book
um but I would know and if I if I
believe what I say I do which is that
I'm the ultimate judge during an
executioner of my own self-esteem
then I'm the only person
who can say good job or not and
unfortunately I have incredibly high
standards and so I can either just
always feel like a failure because I
always fall short of my own standards or
I can create a standard that I I
willingly and consciously accept which
is that I will do enough work that there
is nothing left to be done and that
means that I can also do fewer things
which means I have to be more selective
about the things that I choose to do but
when I do them they will be done well
and they will be done right
they say the true hell is on the person
that you are meets the person that you
could have been yeah and
a lot of the time I think we look at uh
sports stars I'm watching this
quarterback on Netflix at the moment and
is Patrick Mahomes it's just this
artist you know he's he's a halfway
between a warrior and a savant and an
artist and a musician and then
everything rolled together right the
reason that we love seeing behind the
scenes with stuff like that is it is
somebody at the absolute Zenith of their
capacity and they are putting everything
that they can into making this as good
as possible and I think that I sometimes
find myself getting I I certainly did
before I had the podcast
I was wistful that I have the raw
materials to work very hard at things
and I'd never had a Pursuit that I could
have applied it to there was nothing I
remember the first time I ever heard
Peterson say work as hard as you can at
one thing for a year and see what
happens yeah and I'd never had a thing
that I could work I could work hard at
business but the line between your
inputs and your outcomes is so
Meandering and messy that I can always
excuse away good or bad performances as
not being on me and for the most part I
would take responsibility for the bad
ones and not take responsibility for the
good ones because that's how I'm wide
but
I I never had something that was linear
yeah close to linear I'm like I put an
hour in and I get an hour out or more
than an hour out yeah and it's Direct
and then about three years ago I had
this conversation with Dean my video guy
I was like I want to turn pro I read
Stephen pressfield war of art then I
read turning pro so I want to turn pro
with the show what's that mean
what would it mean if I treated this
Pursuit like an athlete does so an
athlete they review game tape and they
do mindset work and they've got a sports
psychologist and they look at what they
eat and they look at what they drink and
they go to bed on time and they're
hanging around with people that are
growth minded and they're getting the
right coaches and all the rest
everything is done in order to
facilitate performance in the thing that
they say they care about um but
everybody has the opportunity to do that
you just need to Define what the thing
is I'm never going to be Patrick Mahomes
right yeah I that I no but I managed to
find my thing
and then nearly kill myself in
dedication toward it there's a photo
that I put up on my Instagram a little
while ago uh two weeks after I ruptured
my achilles yeah yeah that's all that
and I'm in a boot and I've got the
laptop on my lap and we've created this
arm that'll bring the mic to me because
I didn't want to stop doing the podcast
because I'd made this commitment I'm
going to turn pro and for three years we
haven't missed a single episode three
times a week three times a week three
times a week for three years now and
before that it was two a week for a year
and before that it was one a week for a
year yeah and it just keeps on ramping
up and
the opportunity to commit yourself fully
to something that you care about
is
Beyond a blessing and when you do it
the way that you feel once you know that
you've worked hard is great and we said
before we started you got this big thing
coming up which I'm super proud of you
for managing to achieve even though it
hasn't happened yet
um the difference between being nervous
and being excited before you do
something is your level of preparation
in advance of it
if you step out on stage or in front of
half a million people on a webinar which
is the craziest sentence I've ever said
if you step out on stage in front of
half a million people and you've done
absolutely everything
there's nothing to fear
and that's why it's not about what
everyone else will think because when
I'm on stage making that presentation
the only person whose voice I'll hear is
mine and I will know if I have done
everything in my control to be prepared
or not and what's the best thing that
comes out I didn't do everything that I
could to prepare and I managed to fluke
my performance right I managed to like
close my eyes throw the dot and oh wow
it hit the bullseye you'll even know
that they'll even be guilt you won't
even be able to fully enjoy your success
because you'll have tarnished it with
your lack of input and what's
interesting is that when you start
defining your own success that way it
actually starts to feel under your own
control
but the downside is you realize that you
can do very few things and then all of a
sudden life feels very short because
you're like shoot there's like not that
many things I can do before I die if I'm
going to actually do my best and what
was interesting is I was talking to a
CEO friend of mine he's a public CEO
um and he was like I need to start
making content right I'm like if you're
like managing a billion dollar company I
was like you're doing okay man but
because of that type of person he's like
I need to be doing better with my
content right he's got a few hundred
thousand followers anyways and so
I was like all right well how many
pieces of content you're putting out a
week and he was like well I mean I put
out one a day
and I was like dude I was like we put
out 300 a week
and he just he didn't even respond he
just took he just like pursed his lips
and nodded he was like thank you for
resetting my minimum standard it's
always like thank you like and I'm sure
like when you talk to Phil Heath and he
talks about the volume that is required
in order to gain muscle and how much how
how dialed in he is with food and all
the other things
um just the amount of sheer work like
the biggest change in
or I'll say biggest reason that I've had
significantly larger returns or outcomes
that have happened later on in my career
and they continue to get bigger and
bigger is because the minimum standard
for how much work I know I can do on
something has has multiplied a hundred
fold like I look at the first
presentation so I was telling Quinn this
earlier I look at the first
presentations I ever gave and I remember
thinking to myself when I had this I was
like this is a good presentation it's
like 25 slides with like a heading and
like three bullets on each slide and
being like man this is good I'm like
this is a this is this is a pen this is
like an afternoon but in my mind if I
spend a whole day on something that was
like a lot of work now it's I you know I
like using this term like measuring
hundreds which is like measuring
hundreds of hours how many hundreds of
hours have you put towards something
if you do that I promise you the thing
that you're making will get a lot better
and you'll also see how much more you're
capable of which is what I think like my
undertone of listening to what you were
just saying with the podcast is like the
more you do the more you realize you can
do and so what happens is
you're actually even though you're
you're going pro right now you're like
dude next year I'm going pro yeah
because this is now just a minimum
standard of course I work out three days
a week of course I do three podcasts a
week but dude once we have the the
reality TV show and we have the full
crew and we have the headquarter like
because then the path gets lit of where
you're gonna go because you're so
singularly focused and you know you have
no other distractions the attention cost
isn't you're not paying that down
anymore and you're just like how many
times can I repeat this effort and then
that's when you start unlocking Mastery
right like I I have this process for
creating presentations and before we
turn on the mics uh we were talking
about it but it's like I've done a
handful of presentations in my life and
I've gotten decent at making them but
the the process now is so refined which
is like it is game tape it is I make the
thing I do the thing in my head I do it
out loud I watch the recording I edit
the thing I do it in my head I do it out
loud I watch the recording I edit the
thing and I just keep doing it until
it's glass
dude I listen to I listen to every
podcast that I did for probably the
first two and a half years I listened
back every single every single time but
at the time I didn't cringe because I
thought oh you crushed it anybody can go
back and listen to episode one with
Stuart Morton in my old office in
Newcastle upon time and you'll notice
every other sentence that he says I go
it's infuriating it's absolutely
catastrophic my accent's terrible the
everything everything about it is is
awful and yet at the time I thought it
was great here's another interesting
thing I've been thinking about recently
um
when you don't have anything to say no
to it's easy to focus on one thing um
as success begins to get you more
opportunities yeah your ability to say
no becomes increasingly important and
that's something that I'm feeling now
yeah just more attention there's we're
hockey sticking quite aggressively and
I'm not anywhere near like even middling
Zed list Fame yeah but it's enough for
people to see what they think is a penny
stock and decide that they're going to
try and throw the hat in the ring yeah
which means that there's like
20 things I need to say no to every
single week from new people that want to
that want to do a thing why do we try
this thing why don't we do that thing
and why don't we do the other thing it
was a piece of piss five years ago to
say oh three years ago in the middle of
covert to go like I'm gonna go pro and
I'm just gonna focus on this one thing
because what else am I gonna do yeah all
of my nightclubs have been shut down I
got nothing else to do with my life
now oh you said you're gonna go pro
interesting let's see what happens when
you have 30 other things every single
week vying for your attention now let's
see how committed you are
this is my favorite analogy for this
which is the woman in the red dress
but you know every
many people have seen The Matrix if you
haven't seen The Matrix you don't need
to have seen it to understand the
analogy so
Neo is going through the training
program the protagonist Morpheus is his
educator his his teacher and the
education program only has one objective
and so he's walking through the city
people are going left and right he's
bumping into people going through like
crowded New York and then all of a
sudden it's kind of a black and white
palish look it's green black and white
but it's still black and white and then
all of a sudden this woman in a red
dress enters the frame and you can't
help but stare at this one in the red
dress and she's a complete knockout and
Morpheus is talking to Neo trying to
teach him something and as he's talking
he's like Neo we look at me or you're
looking at the woman in the red dress
and he says look again and he looks back
and it's agent Smith holding a gun to
his head and he says freeze and then
everything freezes in the frame and he's
like if you're not one of us you're one
of them and I see that as the
opportunities that we have to say no to
every day it's like another woman in the
red dress and it's become a term that we
use internal ink right it's like it's a
woman in the red dress and the thing is
is that the the more successful you
become or the more able you become the
hotter the woman the red dress is right
like you got a homeless girl that you're
walking you know past on the streets
it's like all dirty but she's got a red
dress on you're like the thing is is
that that Homeless girl when you were in
your apartment actually looks like
pretty hot yeah right she's like you
know I'm not you know I I could you know
right
um but then the better you get the
bigger the opportunities and that's
where you have not your hypothetical 10
but what about your hypothetical 100
yeah and I had a mentor say this to me
right as we sold uh gym launch
he said Alex that you know now that if
it's not a billion it's not worth your
time
and that was such a single
a great razor for all decisions and so
people come they're like hey we should
do this endorsement hey we should
partner with this whatever I mean think
about it like we're in the deal world so
how many delay we get we have 3 000
companies a month that reach out to us
to do a deal that's 100 a day currently
and we've done 13 deals in two years
and so like if you think about from
acceptance rate it's like you know and
I'm not saying you shouldn't apply by
owners go to acquisition icon apply if
you have an awesome business
um but but the point is is that like
you're no muscle isn't really a no
muscle it's just a yes muscle for the
one thing that matters most yep we'll
get back to talking to Alex in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about the number one e-commerce platform
Shopify when I was a nightclub promoter
in the UK I started an online apparel
brand with no experience no coding
ability no marketing background no
inventory management and after a ton of
research I decided on Shopify Shopify is
the Commerce platform revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide you've
probably already heard of it in fact a
lot of your favorite Brands still use
Shopify including gymshark one of the
biggest sports apparel brands on the
planet Shopify is the only tool you need
to start run and grow your online
business without the struggle what I
loved about Shopify was that as we added
in new lines and different verticals it
grew with the business it required zero
experience every single time there was a
problem I was able to sort it myself
that's how simple it is there is a one
dollar per month trial period that you
can sign up for right now with the link
in the description or by going to
shopify.com Modern wisdom or lowercase
that's shopify.com
modernwisdom to take your business to
the next level today heroes and villains
always have the same backstory pain the
difference is what they choose to do
about it villain says the world hurt me
I'll hurt it back the hero says the
world hurt me I'm not gonna let it hurt
anybody else Heroes use pain villains
are used by it
and fukudos here this is a permutation
of what uh Donald Miller said
um who's a great writer and he has a
number of books and he he talked about
the first element the second element of
that quote is the part that I added to
it
um about heroes using pain and villains
being used by it and so
one of the things for people who are not
where they want to be
is that they have pain like Oodles of
pain and I remember when I was starting
out I was looking for passion I was
looking for purpose I was like I just
want to find something that I'm
motivated by but it's the it's the cat
and the cheese it's like we're looking
for cheese but we have all these cat
behind us and all we have to do is look
and remember that they're behind us and
chasing us and so
foreign
if you have the cat and you're staying
in your current situation you're being
used by the cat right you're being used
by the business owner who you know it
doesn't treat you well and is you know
and you're in this job they don't really
want to be in right or you're being used
by
the situation or the context of the
relationship that you're in with the
girl that you're like not that into
right versus saying like this is
terrible
and because of this terribleness
I now have something that I can run away
from and then and then and then like
rather than not looking at the knife or
trying to take painkillers to not feel
the pain it's like completely sobering
up taking the knife and twisting it in
your own heart and being like I'm gonna
do something about this and I
think that that's that's what the heroes
like if we're heroes in our own story
it's not avoiding pain it's choosing
from the very beginning the Alchemy
which is like you have these terrible
situations it's like and you have the
opportunity to turn turn them into magic
and and and Skip or shortcut
all the growth you're going to have in a
really short period of time simply by
twisting the knife and being like I'm
gonna do something about it yeah I think
because
people presume in the beginning that
passion and purpose and meaning and joy
and fulfillment are the things that get
people going but as I've said of all of
the high performance that I've spoken to
the vast vast vast majority of them are
driven by insufficiency and resentment
and terrible parents or terrible
upbringings or a chip on their shoulder
about bullies in school pick your poison
they have decided to use that to create
the activation energy right you can
lower your action threshold and increase
how many points you have to prove it's
like oh I I want to live a better life
yeah that sounds good it's like I want
to prove the bullies that said I was a
worthless piece of in school wrong
it's like that's some potent
fuel I do believe that scaled over a
long enough time it's toxic and I don't
think that it's necessarily how long
like a lifetime yeah right like but you
I mean it'll it'll fuel you for a decade
pretty well yeah and I think that I look
at me I look at you know I was bullied
pretty badly in school and was an only
child and had expectations from parents
and and you know I combined all of those
things together
and I did have a chip on my shoulder and
I did want to prove to the world that I
was worthwhile and I did want people to
to realize that they had doubted the
wrong person
yeah yeah damn right I do
I think being really specific about your
pain is helpful
so like even being specific about the
cheese really specificity in general is
helpful but like even more so like what
is the twisting the pain what is
twisting the knife like what is how do
you operationalize twisting the knife
right instead of being like I hate my
life right it's
I hate the way Andrew makes me feel when
he says that I'm a piece of and I'm
not going to amount to anything
comma because he's right
like why does it hurt me like if someone
says Alex you're a piece of you're
not gonna amount to anything if someone
accuses you of being polar fat right I I
would have I'd be like I have evidence
to the contrary so this will probably
not bother me but the things that bother
us are the ones that you know have an
element of Truth or sometimes not an
element are comprised almost entirely of
Truth and we just want to look at it and
so I think it's
it's the the twisting the knife is
looking in the mirror and saying what if
they're right
success is the only Revenge as you
expand they shrink into irrelevance as
you get louder no one can hear them you
don't beat them you cast a shadow so big
no one can see them to begin with when
people copy they copy the wrong stuff
because they don't know why it worked to
begin with and when it breaks they don't
know how to fix it because they didn't
build it so don't sweat it copycats will
always be behind
good
but success is the only Revenge it is
such a lovely
there's that um let me tell you the
story behind it damn right yeah
so I was 15 years old so this was really
early in my life still jacked still
jacked always jacked permajact and I uh
it's gonna sound so lame so
I had this teacher so I'm freshman in
high school and I might have been 14
whatever the ages and I'm walking
through the hallway and this this
teacher is like an admin of some kind
walks out of his office and he's like
he's like son and I was like I'm like
eaters in trouble what am I gonna do
he's like you work out and I was like no
he's like why not I was like I don't
know how he's like
I'll show you he's like you got the
jeans
and so that teacher Mr Gibbons
um ended up working out with me every
day in high school and showed me how to
work out and he probably saw on some
level that I was some angsty teenager
that felt angry about whatever and I
during our workout sessions would be
like this guy said this to me like he
you know you know or like this oh
whatever
and I was like man I'm gonna come back
at our 10-year reunion and I was like
I'm gonna show him I was like he's gonna
be working for me like blah blah right
and he's like no he's not and I was like
what do you mean I was like let me just
have my moment he's like no he's not
he's like and you're not going to do
that not if I have anything to say about
it when you come back for that 10-year
reunion and I was like what do you mean
he's like because if you come back at a
10-year reunion and say hey John
like everything I have look at me now
he's like the guy's gonna laugh and be
like you did all of this to try and
prove me wrong man I feel sorry for you
and when he said that when he actually
played out what my like Revenge fantasy
was in real life I realized it looked it
looks stupid yeah I looked like the beta
in the situation right and so he
was like the only thing that you can do
is win so big
that all of them constantly compare
themselves to you and then you'll forget
they exist
and he's and that's when he said he said
success is the only Revenge he's like
it's not the best revenge he's like it's
the only one there's no other Revenge
because everything else is petty
everything else does show that you were
thinking about these people all day long
which means they win by default he's
like all you can do is think about your
goal and winning he's like and when you
win that's when you become so big that
they shrink into irrelevance you cast a
shadow that no one even can see them
behind you
this is the Nuance I think on on the
previous point when we were talking
about the toxicity of that fuel long
term you can see me light up yeah
well I think that when you think about
um
the activation energy of using the
things that you don't like well you have
to be careful that you're using them and
that they're not using you still and a
lot of the time
I get this and in my mod juvenile
moments I I see myself do this where
I'll know that there's a game that
somebody else that I don't like cares
about and I'll imagine myself playing
that game to beat them so that I can
stick it to them right purely for the
reason of sticking it to them let's say
that there's someone that really cares
about being in shape and I'm not in as
good shape as I have been in the past
and I know that with muscle memory if
you give me 18 months and a good amount
of testosterone like the thing that they
care about
I would be able to make them feel really
bad about right okay so I would hijack
my own Direction yeah
purely to try and prove somebody else
wrong in a desperate and somehow believe
that that's me taking control of my life
are you kidding me I'm allowing them to
ventriloquize me yeah through pain that
they didn't even mean to give me yeah
the woman in the black dress ah the
black pill equivalent right well like
now it's like not even a distraction
from your main goal it's like
I'm gonna make a new goal just to wrong
this person and then somehow make make
up the story that I'm in control of my
life when I'm I'm really just acting in
complete reaction to this person and so
in so doing in beating them at their own
game they've already won by default yep
because they got me to change the game I
was playing forget about who won it's
like dude you were over there and now
you're over here I see this with a lot
of people I I think that it contributes
to a lot more of why and how people
adopt societal Norms the the resentment
that they have it's it's not just other
people want this thing therefore I
mimetically want to do this thing too
it's I know that other people will
respect me and that my resentment will
feel Justified and manifest if I win at
it and that's really compelling that's
like a motivational spit roasting coming
in from both ends and it's
it's really really powerful and you need
to be careful I mean I think you know
one of the really early blessings and
I'll be on it like this is where I think
I was fortunate right like I I realized
when I was about
28 right
um that I had been trying really hard to
beat I mean you'll notice a common theme
with a lot of my stories but I have one
Central person that I was trying to
prove for a very long time which was my
father
um and we're on good terms by the way
because I always get that question
but uh this was after I left and he
disapproved of my whole thing and for
five years we didn't talk very much and
so he calls me up
um to he says hey you're going to want
to sit down for this and I'm like okay
what are you pregnant you know um
and so he says I'm sorry and and I was
like for what and he was like for
everything right now mind you like it's
a middle eastern father born in Iran to
a middle to a middle eastern father
there who was even more legit like when
where my father was born women weren't
allowed to drive cars cars came with
drivers with them when you bought them
the driver came with the car we're like
he was born in a very different world
like fathers don't apologize to Sons it
just it was it just wasn't that way and
I have a little bit more a little bit
more awareness than I did then and I can
see that now but for me I was like
now you apologize you know what I mean
um and so rather than take it for the
Olive Branch that it was uh I said
I didn't care
about your opinion five years ago when I
left I was like I don't care now
and he was like well we'll see how long
your success lasts and so
what could have been a really nice
exchange ended up becoming pretty pretty
ugly but the the main point there was
that I wanted to in the beginning like
make as much as my father then it was
making more than my father and then it
was make more than my father had ever
made in his entire life and once I had
achieved that I realized that
as much as like it sounds terrible to
say this but like I was trying to beat
him
at his game
and and this is pretty alive in a lot of
a lot of Asian culture same thing making
money is a big you know like when my dad
would introduce somebody be like this is
so and so he makes this much a year like
it was just really clear like this is
how much status someone has and so like
it was really deep for me
um but it was only when I realized that
I had won at his game that I realized I
never even asked the question of like
what game am I trying to win and I don't
know how many people are actually trying
to win at a game that they didn't even
set the rules up for so many when
they're in it and that's why I say like
I think I was fortunate that I you know
I hit a really tough goal because my dad
was is a successful man
um relatively early on
um
but that that for that exchange and then
think like and then reflecting black and
feeling terrible about myself from like
saying what I said and then I was like
I'm
I did everything that I've done to this
point to beat him beat my father the man
who actually raised me who tried to make
me the best man I can and when I think
when I really start thinking about it
I'm like
I like who I am
he raised me
so doesn't that mean that he might have
been the perfect father
and then that really messes me and so
yeah so go ahead well it's just it's
hard to think
that the people you used to have
contempt for or distaste or hatred or
whatever
shaped you in a way that you couldn't
have been and I often think about how
the things I'm most proud of in myself
are the light side of something that I
was so embarrassed about that's so
ashamed about
um you know being an outcast as a kid
meant that uh I
love or I'm capable of being on my own
Way Beyond how anybody else is yeah so
far beyond it I can work on my own in
solitude
for an endless amount of time I can
outwork anybody in solitude why because
I spent
almost all of my time between the ages
of 6 and 16 in my bedroom listening to
audio tapes right listening to
audiobooks and like throwing like a
tennis ball against the wall or like
playing with my like Mighty
Mouse from Mars or whatever they were
called what was it called Biker Mice
from Mars that was it
um and that was what I did yeah
so
but I I all of that discomfort and all
of the challenges that I went through
there are the thing one of the things
that I'm so proud of myself for now Okay
so what if I look back and I said well
all of the the
um
The Bullying that I went through and the
challenges of feeling alone and being on
the outside of social groups meant that
I developed such attenuation and
attention and focus and an ability to
distill down what's happening socially
which is why I became one of the best
club promoters in the UK for a decade
and a half right
because for all of my school life I'd
been obsessing over how Alex wears his
tie maybe that's why he has friends and
I don't have friends or the particular
brand of shoes that he's wearing or the
like he carries his bag on that shoulder
and I call him carry mine on this
shoulder because I couldn't deconstruct
why I didn't have friends and everybody
else did right okay so looking back
would I have rather
had the friends right and had the
brother or sister and not developed this
skill
I can't split test life so I don't know
right but my life's ended up pretty good
right and I'm happy with it so I need to
not only look back at that stuff as
something not to hate but something to
genuinely be thankful for and that is
frankly something I'm still working
through
what yeah it goes It goes back to the
first thing which is like the most
traumatic events that happen in our life
you know they happen for us not to us
but when you expand the time Horizon
like
those things and to be fair there are
people who do have really crappy things
happen to them and then it destroys them
and then that's it and then they're just
done and that's all it is not everyone
has like a moderate amount of childhood
bullying and an only child with like
parents that care about them or whatever
like because you were a child coping
with the world with the coping skills of
a child
I'm still largely that as an adult
Infantry
and so
um
but I think that I mean the keep the at
least for me you know my key takeaway
from both both of these kind of stories
is more that
all of the all of the the negative
things that happen on the micro have the
opportunity
if double down on to be huge wins in the
macro and sometimes in ways that just a
micro win would never have the ability
to be doubled down on and become a
capital w in in the macro
this is probably one of the heaviest
Hammer blows I think for today this next
one this is a real anger tweeting no
it's not it's an existential one you've
already achieved goals you said would
make you happy yeah
you've already achieved goals you said
would make you happy
Alex's notes to self right
[Laughter]
um
because we all know the happiness
formula which is
um when this happens I'll be happy right
when X I'll be happy or if x I'll be
happy
um
and so we you know I've set up that
equation I'm sure I know you've never
set up this equation for yourself in
your life but you know I've set that up
and I think that just serves as as my my
biggest reminder
um but it's also why I probably am a
pretty existential nihilist overall
um because I I've had so much evidence
that none of those things quote brought
me joy but the things that we were
talking earlier about anticipation being
kind of the hot button on Pleasure yep I
feel like the hot button on Joy for me
is what I'm doing right now so like I
haven't done the event yet right I
haven't I haven't given the presentation
but when I'm in the Rocky cut scene of
like of beating I'm not gonna say
beating the cow carcass I'll say that
was like
um
I was trying to avoid certain words
anyways
um that when I'm when I'm when I'm
putting that work in and doing the Reps
like that's when I'm actually my most in
flow and enjoying myself the most and so
it's actually a lie that I've been
telling myself that like once the
presentation goes well I'll feel good
because in some ways now I feel like
when the presentation happens I'll be
disappointed because I won't get to do
this anymore I'll have to find something
else to pick as a Target so that I can
get back into my Rocky cut scene and so
I think that that that has taken some
time and I've gotten better at it I
really do think I've gotten a lot better
at it
um at least recognizing because the more
the more times I've I've had W's and
then realize that right afterwards I
felt nothing
I had to think back of like what are the
things that I enjoyed most in my life
and it's always in Pursuit and I'm like
well then
why don't I set something really big
really far so I can be in Pursuit for
the longest period of time possible and
that's where I think a lot of people
from the outside you know they cast
their expectations of Life onto me and
say I wouldn't live my life that way
you're always you're always working
you're always doing these things but
it's like I'm actually always spending
my time in Pursuit because in Pursuit is
my button for enjoyment well what about
if
it wasn't
achieving the thing at the end if the
reason that you set yourself goals is
exclusively to motivate yourself to
enjoy the route toward those goals and I
know that it's not the destination it's
the journey it's kind of cliche and I
think this is is slightly subtly
different which is that
it's actually about setting the
destination without the destination you
wouldn't do the journey yeah like the
way that you set goals and then achieve
them and the dopamine and the trigger
that you get
um I often think about the balance
between like serotonin Chris and
dopamine Chris and I don't even know the
difference between that it's like am I
feeling sort of lovey and present and
and and wanting to connect with people
or am I driving toward a thing because I
have a goal that's in front of me and
I'm very sort of dopamine Chris yeah a
lot of the time
um but I genuinely think that if you
remind yourself these are the golden
years yeah like this right now yeah this
when you look back
these will be the golden years right
when I had my health I had my full
mental capacity I had control of my
bladder I had all of the money that I
needed to do the things that I wanted to
crush it with my friends to fly around
America and film these podcasts or to
launch this book that I spend all of
this time on and you can even see it in
the micro you can even see it when you
look back on
stuff that you've done in your
day-to-day business or when you what you
did at University
what were the times that you enjoyed was
it when success success came to you
easily or was it when you stayed up and
ordered dominoes because you had that
project that needed to be in at six in
the morning and you ran an all-nighter
and John slept under the the table and
and everybody ordered monsters and then
the next morning we got it done
what was good about that was it when you
submitted it or was it the dominoes and
the 3am sleep under the table because
I'm pretty sure it's that
I love this as a side note
um
but one of the things that really
motivates me or one of my most powerful
motivational frames is thinking about
the person that I want to become as the
destination
and thinking like I want to be
Bulletproof
I want to be bulletproof in these ways I
want to be bulletproof in my marriage I
want to be bulletproof in my business
Etc
and I think about that man whoever I
want him to be like we said hell is when
you look at who you could have been
and realize that you're not that person
and then I think if I were to make that
man
what would I put that man through to
make him who he is
like it wouldn't be easy times it
wouldn't be quick wins it wouldn't even
be easy wins
it would be the the toil and the
struggle of achieving and reaching for
things
that are right out of grasp that are
right above my threshold and continuing
to do that to like lift the weight to
build the muscle to break it down and do
it over and over again because like
that's what creates the character traits
that are the man that I want to be and
so when I'm going through those like
really harder times I like to think of
like looking in my mental mirror of like
I'm making you I'm not there yet but I'm
making you
and that has helped me get through some
of the harder times
and from a gratitude perspective
my my most powerful frame for gratitude
has been thinking about my 85 year old
self
waking up as my 30 year old self
and all of a sudden looking at Layla and
be like man I remember when we were this
young and then looking out the window
and being like man you know Vegas wasn't
even developed like there's no flying
cars yet like man they were still used
gas like this is so cool and I get out
of bed and I'm like and my elbows don't
hurt my knees don't hurt right because
I'm thinking about my 85 year old self
would think and you know we're talking
about whatever but it it it allows me to
enjoy the mundane in a way that I know
that I would give everything that I had
when I was 85 to enjoy again and it's
just it's a it's a Trippy frame but like
if you can think like what would 85 year
old me would be like I'm just not my
body doesn't hurt you know what I mean
like I actually have energy like I can
think clearly I don't have brain fog
because I'm 85 right and that has been
probably my single most powerful frame
on feeling grateful and allowed me to
feel more present at times when I start
like when I start to feel like I'm going
through the motions and just like
clicking in the routine and just like
day after day after day and they feel
the same that's been my biggest slowdown
where I can pull the reins and be like
just an in my mind you it lasts a few
minutes but when I think back on the
days where I when I use that frame the
part of the day that I remember was just
a few minutes that I use it so I did
this episode with Sam Harris a lot of
people have problems with Sam Harris I
found the time that I spent with him
unbelievably enjoyable I sat opposite
him and a couple of times caught myself
thinking I am having so much fun doing
this and he said this thing and I really
wish that I'd ask them another question
I should email him about it um
I was talking about presence and and the
importance of presence and you could use
it as a proxy for gratitude and he said
that really what you're aiming to do
is find small moments in the day when
you just
open up and realize what's happening
yeah right like Conor McGregor won the
featherweight title twice because he won
the interim because Aldo was injured
right and then he won against Aldo and
somebody asked him
what are you going to do differently
this time again before the Aldo fight
that you didn't do against the in the
Mendes fight he says
this time I'm going to be present and
there's this photo of him and he's stood
yeah like this at the weigh-in and
you've got this entire yeah
stadium in front of him and he stood
like that he said the first time he did
it he couldn't remember it because he
was just yeah drowning in the in in what
was next yeah and
what I really loved that Sam said and I
think that
you know you look at somebody that's a
master meditator or you set yourself
High bars for what it means to be
mindful and you realize that you can be
present with a sip of a coffee okay I
can be present with this one sip of a
coffee and then it like sand in your
hands or like trying to remember a dream
it just evaporates yeah right okay well
what if your goal was just to try and
get five of those a day yeah what if
that was it what if being mindful was
just five moments when
you allow yourself to be where your feet
are where your feet are underneath you
and then what if you tried to just
string like two of those together five
times a day like just this first Sip and
then as I put it down the view out of
the window oh my God like that's two
things in one and then I can do that
five times and it it if I'd asked him I
would have said
really is the path to just increase the
frequency of the times that you are
where your feet are underneath you
uh and one other cue that I love that I
got from an embodiment coach is the
times when you see in your peripheral
vision you're looking and the way that
our vision actually works your focused
so heavily on what's directly in front
of you if there's ever a Time when you
see what's out here
you realize that it's impossible to see
all of that and not be in the present
moment because you naturally just opened
yourself up and I love that cue so
during the times when I'm doing things
like that same episode I'm like the next
question and there's millions of people
watching and all this stuff and there's
this guy in front of me and he's super
smart or whatever
ah
this is cool just that one
moment and that when I look back on that
episode that's what I enjoyed
that's what I enjoyed about it so I
think that being where your feet are
underneath you and allowing yourself to
open up and stringing those together
largely allows you to
enjoy being whilst you're in the process
of becoming
it's also interesting
those moments
you can capture a moment independent
from your surroundings because a lot of
times those moments you're not thinking
about the goal that you have the meeting
that you have the the prep that you have
to do for some talk or some podcast or
whatever it is and
a camera where I heard this but they
were talking about Gladiator the movie
and the film opens with this like little
bird on a bow right with like the the
leaves and whatnot and then they zoom
out from that little bird on the on the
on the bow and it's this disgusting war
scene right and so it's kind of like
micro macro micro
um of how no matter how tough whatever
the moment that you're going through is
if you can just take a picture of the
corner of the room and look at the
beauty in that right of being present in
that moment even if it's the suffering
right like you get punched and you're
spitting blood out but it's like this
moment that you capture then all of a
sudden like everything Fades away and
you are present and so it can take this
what would be a brutal war scene of
death and dismemberment and the thing
that makes it memorable is the zooming
in on a detail yeah and so it's like if
we're going if you feel like you're
going through through life too fast it's
like just look for a detail
whenever I wanted to try and get myself
back into the present I used to have
brain fog a lot in my 20s oh really and
maybe not brain fog maybe just the
clarity of my thoughts now is so much
better than it used to but I don't
know maybe
it was just the drugs I don't know um
but one of the things I used to I used
to have this I still have this BMW sat
on my drive
with a perforated steering wheel and I
remember that if I ran my thumbs across
the steering wheel and I really felt the
perforation really felt it or I'd do it
with a leaf I'd pick a leaf up yeah and
I'd really feel the sensation of the
leaf I couldn't think about anything
else you can only have one thought at
one time you cannot think two things
right yeah you have a super computer
inside of your head and it's got one
megabyte of ram yeah so just think the
one thought we'll get back to talking to
Alex in one minute but first I need to
tell you about surf shark VPN if you're
browsing the internet without a VPN it's
like dancing in a muddy field without
any shoes on you can do it but it's not
good for you if you're using a public
Wi-Fi network the internet admin can see
all of the data going back and forth
between yourself and the internet all of
this is protected with surfsharkvpn plus
it gives you access to the entire
world's Netflix Library any territory
that you want if you're anywhere outside
of the US you can access way more Marvel
series and movies over here than you can
in your domestic territory and if you're
in the US maybe you could watch some
Japanese anime or get access to the
in-betweeners best of all it's available
across unlimited devices your laptop
your iPad your phone even your smart TVs
and there is a 30-day money-back
guarantee so you can buy it and try it
for 29 days if you do not like it
they'll give you your money back you can
get next elusive offer from surfshark
today three months free and that 30-day
money-back guarantee by going to
surfshark.deals slash modern wisdom
that's surfshark.deals slash modern
wisdom okay so this next one me and you
text each other pretty frequently about
we've seen this cool thing in someone's
repurposed like one of the things that
we've done which is cool and it makes me
feel good that things that we've said or
that you've said largely get repurposed
um this is something that hadn't
happened before which is you misquoted
me
foreign
but improved the quote so this was like
the human centipede of content creation
and then I named it okay so this is
famous seesaw when you're on your way up
everyone roots for you because you
remind them of their dreams when you're
at the top everyone tears you down
because you remind them that they gave
up on them
and you have one which is for anyone who
needs a reminder no one is going to hate
on you for doing worse than them
and this is interesting because
kind of like the challenges you face
in the beginning
you don't have anything to say no to
therefore the woman in the red dress is
easy to say no to or there are fewer
women yeah
this is a challenge that nobody is going
to give you any sympathy for yeah it's a
very unique category of challenge
because the total addressable market for
sympathy is basically zero
because almost everybody is on their way
up and very few people are at the top
and the people that are at the top are
seen as having a degree of privilege
that almost legitimates you twisting the
knife are you poking the finger this is
how public figures can have normal
everyday people on Twitter say
unspeakable like heinous things to them
dehumanizing things because they do not
see them as human right they don't see
them as a person there isn't a person on
the other side of this there is it's
they're a representation there are a
menagerie of of ideas therefore I can
say whatever I want to them because
they're not they're not really a person
but they are and the fact that
before there is any status associated
with tearing you down
no one is incentivized to tear you down
and you haven't changed did the
Lewis Capaldi documentary I've watched
this twice now no Lewis Capaldi is the
singer Scottish singer amazing dude
really fascinating story suffering a lot
with mental health
make this first album and billions
billions of streams World Tour
phenomenal and he's playing songs that
he wrote in 2017 and played in working
men's pubs around Scotland the same
songs go to number one so not just that
he's become better he's the same guy
yeah the same guy and maybe his
Productions improved maybe his recording
quality has improved he's got better
mastering in his voices voice coaching's
got a bit better but he's largely the
same person
he hasn't changed
and he has this quote halfway through
and it really spoke to me and he said
Fame doesn't change you it just changes
everybody around you yeah
and that's
when you're on your way up everyone
roots for you because you remind them of
their dreams when you're at the top
everyone tears you down because you
remind them that they give up on them
that really yeah that spoke to me I
wrote an essay on this because I'm a
psychopath yeah when I was a gym owner
so a lot of people don't know this but I
got a writing scholarship in college
like I was a vice president of the
newspaper I was uh editor of the
creative writing magazine so like I've
been writing for a long time I enjoy
writing
um and I wrote this essay I said I think
the title of it was
um everyone believes in the American
dream until it comes true
and I remember because what had happened
was everybody when I when I was sleeping
on the gym floor right like you know I
was the I was the underdog and everyone
you know my clients were all like oh
good for you you know you're going after
your dream they'd see my blanket and my
pillow in the corner of the gym and they
knew I was sleeping there and it was
evident you know I I lived there
um I didn't have a shower I didn't have
a shower to go to the YMCA to go shower
um and that everybody was like Pro me
and then people come in they sign up
like I'm gonna I'm gonna support you
right and then within nine months I had
hired people and I had a manager and I
pulled up and I remember I walked in the
lobby and all the same the same people
were like ah boss man's here oh you're
not too good for us now right
and I remember being so Jarred by the
experience and I was like
you guys rooted for me and I was like
and now I I did what you said you were
rooting for me to do and that was when I
realized that people want you to do well
but not better than them
and
I was like I had gone from Underdog to
the man
and I was like when does that happen and
the litmus test of when it happens is
depends on who the person is because for
the person who was working at my gym who
you know was was a janitor or a cleaner
it happened really quick right for the
people who were more successful uh it
took longer and then you know the only
people at the end who would still for me
were the business owners who were doing
way better than me right who were still
members of my gym and so that was a
really interesting experience that
happened when I was 23 and that was the
first time I went from Underdog to the
person that someone would want to attack
but I had a performance coach tell me
this he said
hatred isn't
isn't something you avoid he said it is
a requisite for Success he said if you
get no hate you are not successful
and for some reason that just like
really stuck with me because then it
just like rather than it being this
thing that I was trying to avoid it
actually became a leading indicator or
an indicator that I was on the right
path in achieving things and so I think
that's why I mean I I don't I don't want
two horns or anything
um but in terms of like
my ability to deal with the naysayers
and things like that I feel like I'm
pretty good at it like it doesn't really
bug me very much
um and I think in large part it was
because of how it's framed at least how
you know in this discussion how it was
framed for me early on which is that no
one hates you from above
and even you know even when I think back
about like the bullies and whatnot that
you had earlier like even in Middle
School like there were things that I had
that were going for me that I couldn't
recognize because of course everything
that comes easy to you are things that
they're easy to use you don't think that
they're you know new or interesting or
cool and but like at the same time I was
like I'd Advanced a grade in multiple in
multiple subjects I had you know
Straight A's I worked really hard I was
in shape right and I but I had these
people who would hate but I you know you
internalize it but like now I can look
back and be like it's kind of like the
the parents were like it's because she's
into you right no it might not be the
same that way but but just thinking
about it as an indicator that
the hate is actually the light that
you're on the right path
we spoke about this last time that
nothing is going to be worthwhile that
doesn't come with an Associated amount
of discomfort
therefore when you start to feel
friends around you and the people that
you used to be able to speak a Common
Language with
start to push back and start to make the
quips of oh not drinking tonight yeah oh
you must be too cool for us now
I know it hurts I know it hurts
that is the lead indicator not even the
lagging indicator that is the lead
indicator that you're doing the right
thing
and a lot of people listen to this
podcast I get messages from people like
hey man I'm a 22 year old rugby player
from the northwest of of the UK I live
in Cumbria none of my friends uh
understand me I want to do personal
growth I don't want to live in the UK
and when I listen to Modern wisdom I
Fearless alone and it it makes
me tear up because I'm like like I
see me in that person I see me in that
and
the it's so hard to reframe it
the pushback you are getting is the
indicator that you are doing the right
thing
it is
and if you can reframe
the distaste that you get from other
people
as the same as that
because they're projecting the things
that they know they should be doing that
you are doing that they're not doing
and you remind them of that and so it's
that it's even so even though the
mountain that you're climbing is
actually a smaller one than the one that
you ultimately want to climb you're
actually at the top of their mountain
and so they start tearing you down so
like that's where the the Underdog Story
that we said the very beginning of this
with the quote which is like on the way
up they root for you and then when
you're at the top they try and tear you
down because you remind them of the
dreams that they couldn't accomplish
right and so you quitting drinking are
you staying in to work on your side
hustle or your project or the business
that you want to launch the podcast
that might be you might be at the top of
their mountain and so they are tearing
you down because now you remind them
that they haven't done it and it's
purely a projection of them onto you and
has nothing to do with you and that
I hope that that Comforts someone
because what you said I think is like if
you're going through that right now and
like and I promise you every single
person who wants to do something with
their life and has done something with
their life has gone through the exact
chapter that you're going through and
it's the lonely chapter it's the chapter
where you you're you don't fit in with
your own friends but you don't have the
outcomes yet to fit into a new group of
friends and you're doing this thing
you're consuming content on the internet
you're you're doing these free tutorials
online to try and figure out how to set
up a podcast and where do I host this
thing and then there and and you're
going through this and you're like am I
is this even worth it because you have
no signs of success right but if there's
anything that you can take away from
what we're saying right now is that
the sign of success is the hate that you
get along the way and what you can't do
is bend the knee to their hate and fit
back into the Conformity because it's
comfortable and it's warm because
like in The Matrix when Trinity opens
the door when when Neo's about to go
take the red pill and he wants to get
out of the car she says Neo you've been
down that road and you know exactly
where it leads and I know that's not
where you want to be
and then he closes the door like right
now this moment that you're going
through is Trinity opening the door and
being like you could go back but then
you'd have to remember exactly what the
reason was that you decided not to go
out to begin with is because you listen
to this podcast and you consume this
content you're like I can do
more than this like because you are
starting to live in some of that how
where you look in the mirror and you're
like I can do more and you start to see
the person that you could be and you're
like this does start to feel like hell
the reason that it's uncomfortable and
the reason that
I do have sympathy for the people that
see this is
ignorance in some regards is bliss as
soon as you begin to posit an ideal yeah
you then begin to compare yourself to
that ideal and the Gap in potential
between you and the person that you
could have been begins to get more stuck
and
even the slightest glimmer of
wow I can I can read a book or follow a
course or listen to a podcast and then
work really really hard on one thing
and change the thermodynamics of my mind
change the texture of my own existence
day to day because I worked at a thing
and now I understand nutrition you know
I know Kung Fu like I I understand
nutrition or I can I understand how to
sleep well okay as soon as you know that
sleep is important and what you need to
do to do it every single night of bad
sleep that you have is on you yeah
because before you had the excuse that
you're ignorant yeah and guess what
now you don't
every worthwhile goal
is worthwhile because it has a cost
associated with it and so the cost that
you're going through is what makes the
goal worthwhile to begin with because if
what you are setting out to do
were immediately available to you then
it would mean it would be immediately
available to everyone which means it
wouldn't be worthwhile so the very fact
that it's difficult is why it is worth
doing and so like we can't resent the
price tag of the shoes that we want to
buy
we just have to make the decision
whether or not we want to pay it
there's another real Hammer blow you
don't get very touchy feely with like
you know I live in Austin now so I'm
like in in the Psychedelic Mecca of the
United States and people talk a lot
about like
trauma and and Improvement and stuff
like that
self-love is holding yourself to a
higher standard than anyone else does
that's really interesting to me
I think it's believing in the 85 year
old version of you
who's exactly who you want to be and
then
ruthlessly
looking at the discrepancy between the
the pittance of a human that you are now
compared to that man or that woman and
then step by step breaking down the many
differences and starting on the first
one and pulling the thread
I love the idea that
in a truth true self-love a lot of the
time is wrapped in acceptance
and a degree of belonging I reject this
entirely I just want to I just want to
throw it out there that doesn't surprise
me
the idea
that self-love is holding yourself to a
higher standard than anyone else does
you believing in you
more
than anybody else does
is such a first principle's way of
looking at self-love Okay so
I'm supposed to love myself I'm supposed
to support myself and be my biggest fan
but I don't have the most belief in me
so
I'm supposed to have self-love but I cap
my own potential
I have so many thoughts
so right off the bat even the concept of
fan was something that I I if I was if
you're if I was talking to 2013 2012
Alex I would have rejected that notion
not like the the concept of even being a
fan of myself was so foreign to me it
wouldn't been real to me and so I'll
tell you what that Alex internalized
which was that I didn't need to deserve
success but I could still have it if I
did the things that created success and
so it felt like a cheat code where I was
like I can actually be a shitty person
and horrible and suck at everything but
if I still work out and I still eat this
way I can still look this way even
though I don't deserve it and that was
like the first it actually felt like I
was like if for anybody who hates
themselves you can hear me
um that was like my first big shade my
first Solace my first foothold that I
started getting on success was that I
didn't need to deserve it I could still
have it anyways and that was like very
empowering for me
the other thing that you said about
acceptance
so
there's this big movement around
self-acceptance and I want to say that I
wholeheartedly reject it
I
you accept outcomes and you accept
circumstances you accept the fact that
you were dealt whatever hand you were
dealt you accept that you're five eight
you accept that you're black you accept
that you're a woman that's accepting you
trying to rebel against that is you
trying to fight the universe and the
universe is going to win every time
but in terms of you framing acceptance
as saying that
I am comfortable with who I am and I
cannot be better and I must be satisfied
with that
is the biggest embodiment
a failure that I can imagine
is that it's almost it's almost it's
almost egotistical
to say that
there's a difference between saying I am
good enough and I am good
so you could say I am good enough for my
current state based on the work that
I've put into it but I could be better
and so like
you can accept that the work that you
have done has created the outcome that
you've created but you do not need to
accept that the outcome that you've
created is the end-all be-all and the
last outcome that you need to need to
have and so for me like
the only version of acceptance that I
have is that I accept
that the version of myself that I want
to be is is so far from who I am that I
have this massive discrepancy that I
have to overcome and then just breaking
that down one step at a time and
thinking I don't
I don't deserve to be that man but I can
still do the things
that can create it and it also means
that I have to go through the
circumstances that that would create
that man which means that if I have
unbelievable Big Dreams and big goals
then I have to go through hard times
it's like hate the hard times are a
requisite for success and so if you're
going through hard times right now it
means that you're on the path to success
and it's not that you're on the wrong
path it's the feeling of being on the
right path and one of the things that I
talk with with the CEOs in our portfolio
company and I'm I'm going to bring it
back
one of our companies
they were struggling with growth big
company and he was like I honestly the
issue that I have right now he's like I
I don't know how many locations I can
open every month he's like based on the
cash flow that's coming in and out and I
was like this is kind of like the
Morpheus free front but I was like I
need you to freeze this moment I was
like the feeling that you have right now
is that you are missing a finance
function is that they didn't have a good
Finance leader and you're like why is
this relative to what we're talking
about I'll bring it back which is that
if it's the first time you're going
through it you can't recognize the
science because you don't have anything
to compare it to and so hopefully
listening to this podcast and listening
to other people not just you know not me
and Chris but like other people who are
even even more successful whatever
they can at least tell you what it
tastes like they can tell you what the
room looks like they can tell you what
the temperature feels like they can tell
you what it feels like in their bodies
so that when you are going through it
you can say okay I haven't been here
before but this sounds like Albuquerque
this sounds like a missing finance and
that's why having like and if you're in
the early on stages and and you're going
through the like you're going You're
consuming the free content is less stuff
it's like use this because the most
valuable thing you can get is the
context of what the experience feels
like when you're going through it so
someone can describe to you their
experience so that you can relate it to
your present and be like okay I'm on the
right path yeah it's the feeling of
loneliness and uncertainty hang on what
if this what if this is a sign that I'm
not supposed to be here what if this is
a sign that I'm doing it wrong right and
relinquishing that the
if there was a big meta indicator that
you're doing the right thing doing what
everyone isn't doing is already probably
the biggest the single biggest indicator
that you're doing the right thing like
it's it's the if if I could wish nothing
else on my child whenever I choose to
have them in the future is that they
have high agency which is that they are
they make decisions independent from the
opinions of other people and when we
hear words like authentic and original
and things like that it's because the
person starts at square one and says
well what do I want and then they start
building from there I had a conversation
with one of my one of my teammates
um who runs our my LinkedIn
and he said you know Alex it's easy for
you
it's always always a really great start
great way to trigger
really good please
tell me more why do you go on he said
it's it's easy for you Alex to create
this personal brand he's like you have
so many interesting things about you
he's like you dress a certain way you
act a certain way and he said it's
different than everyone else does right
and I said
I don't think that's true I think that
everyone has a personal brand that is
unique and different but everyone
doesn't look that way because they
conform to whatever what they think
everyone else wants them to look like
and so the fact that they are boring and
they resent the fact that they're boring
is because they are living out
reflections of what what they think
everyone else wants them to do and so
all you have to do is start at Square
zero and be like what do I want because
I realized after I got out of gym launch
that I mean I dressed a certain way for
too much because I was the head of an
entire community of gyms and it made
sense for me to dress that way because I
needed to
I needed to look that part right but
when I was at Ground Zero and I was like
okay what do I want and I thought about
it for a long time and I was like well
what would 85 year old me wear I was
like 85 year old me would wear probably
the most functional thing he could wear
because he doesn't care what his shoes
look like he doesn't care what his shirt
looks like he just wants to be
comfortable and so I just started trying
all the things that I could possibly
imagine for shoes shorts hats whatever
to find the thing that I was like you
know what
this is the most comfortable and this
allows me to do the most things in the
most rooms without changing and so
people then are like man that's so
unique but it was actually just saying
if I were to or if everyone was gone
from existence what would I do what
would my work be right how would I dress
who would I date that's a real one who
would I date if no one else told me what
they thought about it maybe someone
different than you're dating right now
and if the person that you would want to
date isn't the person you're dating
right now and the person that you'd want
to date would never date you
then maybe rather than dating these
mediocre mollies or mediocre mats
you take the period of time you go on
the untrodden path you have people
reject you and say oh you're not coming
out tonight you're going to the gym
again right oh I can't eat with us right
she's on it she's on a diet again how
long I'm gonna stick with this one right
because the thing is is that the stick
to it and muscle itself is something
that you work on because if you start a
diet and you failed and you started
working out and you failed if you just
make it longer every time before you
fail you're still making progress and
you're still doing something that
everyone else isn't doing yeah and that
is the biggest meta indicator that you
possibly can is if because
everyone sucks
like so many people are mediocre like
half of the United States is in debt
they don't even have a DOT like they
their their negative net worth
and so like just saying different than
that like the bar isn't High we talked
about this dude go for it I know I know
just go for it the bar has never been
set lower to separate yourself out from
the pack never being set lower and this
is for you know the black pill internet
by the way it is supposed to be One Step
Beyond The Red Pill to see that life and
dating largely for men is uh there's an
uncomfortable reality that if you aren't
blessed with the right physical
attractiveness status or money uh LSM
looks LMS Lux money status if you don't
have the right prerequisites you're
basically doomed you're a genetic dead
end and eat
um is that a bad thing up according to
them
I so okay I'm gonna zoom out real quick
and then I I know I know we're gonna go
on this yeah yeah so if we're looking at
a species right let's look at deer right
A lot of people have deer in their
backyard right well what is natural is
that one buck
inseminates 50 Doe
and he competes with all the other deer
and the reason for that is because then
it actually allows the quote Best genes
to proliferate now best is determined by
what actually continues continues on
right perilously close to Eugenics here
Alex well I'm just talking about I'm
just talking about deer I'm just talking
about deer if anyone I'm just talking
about deer I'm not saying this is what
it should be but the the point that that
I wanted to make was not I think where
everyone thinks I'm going with this
which is that
a lot of the you know the black whatever
you just said right black pill
um I would imagine are casting an
expectation on the universe that it
shouldn't be this way
why not and this is exactly like the
hater who says you're not going to
amount to anything and the reason that
it hurts is because you're like what if
they're right
and then like staring at the mirror with
that question of like what if they're
right what if I am out of shape what
like because the thing is is that like
in order to be the top quote one percent
or even the top ten percent shoot up or
even just above average right you just
need to not be overweight dude you need
to not be overweight right you need to
be gainfully employed
the bar is so low the bar is so
unbelievably low uh I got this idea I
got it I gotta teach you about uh the
alpha history fantasy right modern men
who are angry at a world they feel has
rejected them mistakenly believe that
they would have somehow done better in
medieval times they are adamant that the
chance of them being Genghis Khan is
greater than the chance of them being
cannon fodder peasant number one million
three hundred and seventy three thousand
whose Favela was sacked and destroyed
and it's this wistfulness for the past
and dude I get it like if you feel lost
and alone and like nobody understands
you and like you've been forgotten and
things shouldn't be this way guess what
they've always been this way and right
now the bar has never been set lower if
you have the opportunity to sit down and
listen to me and Alex waffle on for
three and a half hours you have the
capacity the conscientiousness the
wherewithal to be able to go out
tomorrow and take one thing
that you've hit from today
this is this is something I wanted to
get onto which which I think is
important which is oh sorry avoiding the
mental masturbation you know we can do
this thing and and like
speed quotes Into The Ether and
like a like an Uzi right just unloading
all of these different things and I
think that a lot of people feel uh a
general overwhelm of indexing of
information and oh my God I'm learning
all of this stuff and I don't feel like
I'm making any progress and I really
wanted to try and cut through this at
some point in the conversation today as
well which is
Tim Ferriss has an idea called the good
sticks okay
I when I first started out on this
journey of personal growth felt guilty
because I didn't have a perfectly
curated Evernote external brain with
nested folders and all of my book
summaries and I was supposed to keep all
of this thing and how am I going to
remember it and blah blah blah
five and a bit years later
people come up to me and ask one of the
most common questions to get asked is
how the do you remember all of the
things that you remember
two things first off I don't remember
anything that I don't care about and the
second thing massive amounts of exposure
those are the only two things that are
going on
I've done 670 podcasts in five years
for hours and all of the reading I had
to do beforehand and all of the
listening I had to do beforehand as well
and I didn't stress myself about what I
had to remember so if you listen to this
three in a bit Hour podcast
and you go
they talked they said a lot of words
there Alex said a lot of words Chris in
a lot of words
what's the one thing that you couldn't
stop thinking about and then maybe
nothing except like we failed
if there's one thing that you can't stop
thinking about that story about the kid
from Cumbria that time when Alex had to
drive across the country
that's the thing that is the thing and
allowing yourself to
naturally select whatever the most
important learning is from the content
that you consume
is the best way to work out what what is
going to resonate and it's the best way
to act on it as well if you can't stop
thinking about it when you go to bed
tonight and you can't stop telling your
friends about it in the morning and
you've clipped it from this podcast or
any other podcast or any other book or
whatever whatever the thing is that you
keep sending photos of and you keep on
reciting to people and you try and tell
your mum about and she doesn't cast
that is the thing
that you need to work on and you don't
need to do if you take half a thing from
this podcast or any other podcast that
and you work on it for a month
you have made so much progress and do
you understand how blessed you are to
have this opportunity you could have
been born in the Middle Ages before the
Gutenberg printing press when they
wouldn't even give you the Bible in the
common language so that you had to go
through the priest to be able to have a
relationship with God right now you can
search for whatever it is that you're
dealing with find the greatest Minds on
the planet listen to them and then the
next day implement it and you move not
only yourself but you move the world
around you
you get to nudge yourself and the rest
of the world in a direction that you
want to go and you get to feel proud
about it and it's within your control
you have never been more blessed
there's a there's a quote that I wanna I
wanna hit here that I think would be
relevant to we were just talking about
with the people who are sad and alone
and one of the one of the biggest
breakthroughs that I had from a from a
mental perspective was actually defining
emotions for what they are operationally
so sadness
comes from a lack of options or rather a
lack of perceived options and that's why
it feels like hopelessness because you
don't know what to do
but when I realized that sadness meant
that I didn't know what to do it meant
that another way that I could Define
sadness was ignorance and that is
solvable
and so whenever I feel sad now
it's been my trigger to immediately
think
what do I not know what option do I not
see
because the opposite of that is anxiety
which is you have many options and you
have few priorities looks you have many
paths that you could presume you just
don't know which one and so being able
to operationalize what these emotions
felt like so if you feel sad it just
means that you need to go learn more and
that you can do and then all of a sudden
the learning more becomes the option and
they don't need to feel sad anymore
and that was like one of the biggest
breakthroughs from my like mental health
or whatever you want to call it mindset
that Set Me Free and I've taken a lot of
effort to try and operationalize
emotions so that I can either get out of
them or lean into them so like patience
for example right I'm only bringing this
up because I think it might be relevant
to some people is that
most goals are attainable if you expand
the time Horizon even enormous ones like
you can do anything intense you could
walk to the Moon you could do there you
go you can do anything and so for me I
am I would say a naturally impatient
person like I tend to want things
immediately now and you know what you
probably are too
but once I defined patience as figuring
out what to do in the meantime it
allowed me to control what I did because
now like you and I are being patient for
your stock Investments right now as
we're on this podcast we're being
patient for that because we're doing
things in the meantime and so
whenever I felt impatient and wanted to
change course I had to just redefine
what do I need to do today and if you
are sad and impatient then it means that
right now you need to learn what the
option is that you need to go pursue and
then that makes it very much under your
control and so step by step each of
these emotions over time I spent a lot
of time trying to Define them out so
that they no longer control me and I
know how to solve them and then and then
now it just becomes a faster and faster
muscle oh I feel anxiety that means that
I have many options that I don't have
priorities okay what's my priority and
then all of a sudden what used to take
days of anxiety and feeling this you
know frog in my throat was just oh
I need to make a list of all the things
that I'm looking at which one's the most
important ignore the rest and then
I'm good and what you say days takes
minutes
one of yours is
choosing the plan isn't hard doing the
plan isn't hard sticking to the plan is
hard
Charlie Munger said
the money isn't made in the buy and it's
not made in the Cell It's Made in the
weight
and that that like I just feel like
that's such an elegant way of thinking
about it it's like the hard part about
the plan is sticking to the plan like
the plan wasn't bad your first plan was
good because it's easy to go say I'm
gonna work out three days a week for the
next year
and it's a good plan a good plan it's a
pretty good plan and the interesting
thing is that like
a mediocre plant that's stuck to always
outperforms an amazing and perfect plan
that you never stick with to begin with
and I know this obviously from the
Fitness world but applies to everything
and so like the stick to it muscle is
the one that you have to flex and that's
why like if you're going through things
you have especially in the earlier days
like I remember I used to start and stop
and start and stop and I try this thing
I try that thing it's normal because you
haven't you haven't been reinforced
enough of sticking with something right
but the thing is it's like you have to
stick it out long enough that you get
that first carrot you get that first
cookie and then all of a sudden
everything that you did to get there
you're like oh more of that will get me
more cookies and that's and then and
then it just becomes the
self-perpetuating cycle then you get
addicted to working and then you do a
launch to 500 000 people and you lock
yourself in a closet six hours a day for
two years yeah that's exactly that
because I've been rewarded in the past
because the first time I actually spent
a lot of time on a presentation
and I felt good when I walked on stage
and didn't feel anxiety I was like oh I
want this every time yeah and then I had
this the second thought which is the
much scarier thought which is now I have
to do this every time this is the new
Bob this is the new bar I want to round
out something on that sort of black pill
side which is
if you listen to this and you think
must be nice or easy for you to say
I get it like I I get it and if you feel
like there is something
that you can't get over some genetic
societal cultural defect that means that
you do not have the same ceiling that
you think that you should or that other
people appear to have I get it and the
question I would ask is what do you want
like do you want sympathy because I will
happily give you sympathy I know what it
feels like to be someone that has no
belief in themselves and that believes
that you are fundamentally a loser and
that nothing is going to come to you and
that you deserve for nothing to come to
you I understand what that feels like
but what does that mindset get you like
fundamentally what does that mindset
give you okay so let's say let's say
that
you have been dealt as difficult of a
hand as possible
and
yeah
and to quote you to you
I can promise you that there is someone
who has had it worse and has done it
better
I put this clip out a while ago this
like just random talking about a morning
routine thing and it was pretty basic
but it went Interstellar and the
real internet got a hold of it you know
like not your fans but like the real
internet like it we've got the general
public and I got a hold of it the most
common comment was something along the
lines of tell me you don't have kids
without telling me that you don't have
kids right which is must be easy for you
to say I have a daughter to get in the
get up in the morning I'm like okay tell
me what that mindset gets you genuinely
tell me what that mindset gets you it
says I'm in a situation which I cannot
get over and there are things in reality
imposed on me which stopped me from
doing something there is somebody out
there who has three times as many kids
as you and they still do it so what is
it that they've got like what is it that
they're doing have they got an unfair
Advantage what is it tell me
it's also if you take down if you walk
down the natural logic of that statement
who do you blame
if you're saying must be nice or tell me
tell me that you don't have kids without
telling me that you don't have kids
then does that mean that you blame your
child for all the things that you don't
have in life
it's tough tough weight to put on a kid
because I mean I would hope that they
don't see that comment because then
they'd be like wait mom dad like you
didn't live out your dreams because I
exist
tough another one here a sequence
actually that I love
you don't have to feel good about it you
just have to keep going the feeling will
pass but you will remain you are greater
than your feelings going to bed late and
waking up early to work for a few days
won't kill you you're not going to burn
out you're doing what it takes if you're
one of those people that push work-life
balance just remember the people who
like working a lot don't care I've never
regretted trying harder at anything ever
hard times last long but an epic story
feels like a lifetime
nailed it yeah I just think
when I look at you in particular and I
realize this
during our second conversation at the
start of this year
the reason that people get confused
about your
motivation and your workload is that
they don't realize that the thing you do
for work is the thing that you do for
fun that's a fundamental
misunderstanding that people have
and because of that you're prepared to
work hard
and working hard doesn't feel like
wasted time
lots of people associate working hard
with not making progress therefore
working feels like wasting
so the idea that working hard doesn't
make progress is one of the biggest
forces that exists in humanity because
at the end of the day whatever you
amount to isn't going to matter anyways
right and so if there is anything that's
Eternal for us at least as individuals
it's going to be who we become in the
process and so one of my favorite quotes
is the work works on you more than you
work on it
and so if you want to be the best in the
world at something you do the work to
become the best in the world and the
work works on you and so I mean there's
a there's a Biblical proverb I think
it's just like
um there is
there is profit in all labor
and that means that even if
the thing that you're working on right
now doesn't amount to the outcome that
you expected that it would it doesn't
mean that you don't become better
through doing it and so I'll give you a
very real example
so I spent five years building a chain
of gyms so I had six locations and after
that I sold five of them I shut one down
and then I transitioned to doing
turnarounds
in the transition between shutting my
gyms down I got a big payday because I
sold my five gym big for me relative
I took all that money and I put it into
the next thing the partner that I had in
that next thing ended up taking the
money and disappearing filing bankruptcy
and sending it to his girlfriend in
Sweden I couldn't make this up so
there's no way I could get the money
back and he had filed bankruptcy there's
no there's no course of action for a
lawsuit
and so a lot of people would probably go
through that mental situation and think
and I went through this was thinking I
just wasted the last five years like I
literally started a chain built like put
everything into the second location put
everything in the Third location the
fourth location it kept going right I
kept doubling down and then I get my big
payday and I put it all all on black and
then it disappears with one spin of the
roulette and so here I am and I'm like I
have nothing to show for the last five
years of work
but then in the next 12 months I made
more money than I had ever made in my
entire life up to that point the five
years I made I made the I made more
profit the next 12 months than I mean
the last five years times like five
and it was because and this is only I
was only able to really realize this in
retrospect which is why I'm sharing it
which is that
the thing that was the outcome of those
five years was me and the skills and the
experiences that I possessed through
going through it and so whatever the
next Mountain that you're trying to
climb is of course it's going to be
higher but it's going to require you to
go through the smaller mountains to get
to that point so because the more able
you are the more able you realize you
can become and you will get way bigger
outcomes from the things that you have
like the path that led you here then
then you
then you think you can and so
that's why since that moment when I lost
everything and then I was able to make
more in the next 12 months I realized
that no work is wasted because I am the
output of the work not the outcome
and that was one of the biggest frame
shifts for me in never thinking that
work is wasted because the more I work
the bigger my work ethic the more my
work capacity increases and to give an
exercise example because I think it's
it's cool and interesting is that a lot
of people talk about this concept of
overtrendic don't worry I'll bring it
back all right they talk about this
concept of over training I remember I
was talking I had this
a woman that Layla and I are friends
with very successful business owner had
a boy toy with her and he was like
aren't you concerned about overtraining
and I was feeling a little pissy that
day and I said bro once you start
looking like you work out you can worry
about over training I was like until
that point
you don't need to worry about over
training I was being a little bit mean
but I think he he did remember it he did
change the way he trained and he did
gain muscle afterwards so I felt okay
about it now the point of that little
quip right was that
what I explained to him is that your
ability to recover from working out
itself is trainable so when you do more
volume your ability to withstand volume
your work capacity increases and so to
the same degree people are like I feel
burnt out the thing is is that you
either die or you adapt that's it right
and in the Fitness World you either die
get injured or adapt right and since
you're probably not going to die you
really just need to make sure that you
don't get injured and if you don't get
injured and you don't die you get better
and so that mental process in terms of
how I see work has been like the most
self-fulfilling prophecy that I've had
because the more I work the better I get
it working the more productive I am per
unit of time and so and then I get the
outcomes that happen eventually but the
point is and you've probably I mean I
already know you know this but
the outcomes become so irrelevant
compared to the reward that you get in
the meantime because the people who are
experts and this is from my my good
friend Dr Kashi people who are experts
at any skill become experts because they
learn how to become rewarded from the
work itself and so like they don't
actually have something that you don't
it's just that they measure success
differently
foreign
Yourself by your actions not by your
thoughts I became significantly less
disappointed in myself when I started
judging myself only on the actions I
took not the thoughts I had
so
patience is a virtue that I feel like I
haven't had and it's been something that
I've spoken over myself for many years I
was like I'm an impatient person I want
things fast Etc
when I realized that I should use the
same lens that I judge other people on
when I judge myself which is someone
might say I'm a really honest guy but if
I have no evidence that you're an honest
person or when I put you in a situation
where you could be honest and you're not
I would say no you're not now that
person probably thinks of themselves as
honest or to the same degree I'm a
really loyal guy but as soon as I put a
10 in front of you and you've got your
your girl at home you jump you're not
that loyal you just haven't had the
opportunity to show that you're loyal
and so
for me my thoughts about what I thought
I was were actually really negative but
when I try to think okay well I can be
patient if I act patient even if I don't
feel patient and then that allowed me to
start giving myself a stack of
undeniable proof
that I am who I wanted to be and I don't
believe in binary traits meaning like
he's patient or he's impatient or he's
loyal or he's disloyal it's the question
is how loyal are you how honest are you
how patient are you and by switching the
character traits that I wanted to have
into progressions or continuums allowed
me to make progress on them simply by
giving myself more proof or one more
Penny on the scale that says I'm a
little bit more patient than I was I'm a
little bit more patient I'm a little bit
more patient to the point where I have
so many pennies on the scale that I can
say I think I am pretty patient even
though every time I put a penny on the
scale I don't want to put a penny on the
scale I want to get the thing to happen
today I want it to happen yesterday
because why is it taking so long it
didn't take that long for this person
that feels like I feel like I work
harder than them and I feel like I'm
better than them why am I not doing that
but
I put the penny on the scale well
ultimately what is patience is patience
feeling patient or is patient doing the
thing that is patience so Sam Harris in
his first conversation with Joker
willink about 10 years ago they talk
about how courage is an unfakable
emotion and it's such a good frame
you're gonna love this so
he said if you do the thing in spite of
being fearful of doing the thing that is
courage and if you don't do the thing
even though you felt like doing the
thing that is cowardice and I think that
motivation and Patience are exactly the
same if you're patient despite not
feeling patient that is patience yes
that is how it works and that was that
realization that you just said was the
reason for that quote because it was me
realizing that I can actually have these
traits even if I don't feel like I live
those traits and so that's why probably
at least for me when people are like
whatever the trade is like he's so
humble he's so whatever like
you probably will never feel like you
have the trade
but you can still have the trait based
on evidence rather than emotion and I
think that frame of evidence has been I
mean if I had a North star of personal
development for myself it's been just
give myself proof and I mean in so many
ways like the reason that I didn't I
mean I'm going to go on attention but
again I'll bring it back
I didn't talk about how to run gyms
until I had six gyms because I didn't
feel like I was qualified enough to talk
about it and I only started talking
about gyms when so many people were like
dude how do you run your jibs how do you
run your gyms and if I rewind even
before that I didn't feel qualified to
talk about Fitness but I had a six-pack
for a decade you know what I mean and I
had multiple State State records but I
still didn't feel qualified to talk
about Fitness until everyone was like
dude how do you how you do this how do
you strength train how do you how do you
eat this way whatever it is right and so
if you if you can give yourself evidence
the world around you like Fame like your
evidence will change how people treat
you independent of how you feel about it
well this is why the must be easy must
be nice is so flawed because what you're
saying is I see the outcomes and I have
no idea of the difficulty of the inputs
I have absolutely no idea what barriers
you need to get over you could be you
could find it 99 out of 100 difficult to
be patient
and yet you are must be nice for you
you've got that patience Gene you go eat
eat you have no idea how hard it is
for people to do the things that they do
and the people that make it look easy
in some regards contribute to this
problem like I I and this is why I
really love a massive fan of a lot of
your work and I think that one of the
reasons is that it's so honest and and
self-effacing about the challenges and
about the steps that you have to get
through and because the journey is
relatively well narratized and you can
you can track it step by step and you've
created a kind of a cohesive timeline of
how all of this stuff worked there is a
point along specifically your journey
but hopefully mine and other people's
too where people can inject themselves
and say oh I'm at that bit
I'm the 15 year old that I'm at that bit
I resent my parents I've just lost all
my money I I feel like I need to you
know like you have every different
problem that you can encounter in life
is present in Alex's timeline
and I think that that's really important
I think this this is one of the
I would say this is a criticism that I
have about some of the personal
development self-growth and a lot of the
business advice as well
even the bad times are romanticized
and they're not romantic like it
feels like hell it feels like to do
the thing to fail to not feel like
anybody cares about you to not even know
that there's going to be glory in
retrospect yeah
it feels despondent and destitute and
sad and alone
and I get it and I think that the more
visceral
that we can make these stories the
better it is because I know that that's
what would have resonated with me
because I would have gone that's an
undeniable stack of proof that you were
where you said you were
I'll tell you one that maybe will
resonate with somebody in the audience
so I remember when I decided to move so
I moved to California to start a gym or
get into fitness and I got there and the
guy who I said I was going to Mentor
under was like where are you staying and
I was like I don't know I just got here
and he's like what do you mean you don't
know I was like I don't know I just I
just showed up and so he went he said I
could sleep at his place that night the
next morning went to the gym and he got
on chair and said hey
who here is going to house this kid and
one guy came up to me was like I'll give
you a room so I rented one room in a
house for 400 bucks a month
and then when I left that room to start
sleeping at the gym which was an hour
away because I couldn't make the commute
so I saved 400 bucks a month I remember
being actually kind of excited about it
I remember being like man this is an
essential story yeah this is this is my
Rocky cut scene right the thing is that
the rocky cut scene lasts 30 seconds in
the movie
but it can last five years in your life
and when I was sleeping on the gym floor
I'll give you a detail that that'll tell
you that the stack of an entire
um was that I my first gym was
underneath of a parking garage and so
there's these metal dividers in the
ceiling and so cars would drive over
this and it's a Concrete box and so it
sounded like a gunshot like
and it would happen at all hours tonight
and probably the most painful from an
emotional perspective experience that I
would have on a regular basis was that
it was also abandoned enough parking a
lot that college kids kids my age would
go up and party on the roof and so like
while they were partying literally above
my head and making noise that would
prevent me from sleeping
I would be down below in an in a dark
Warehouse in a city that I knew no one
like I was from Baltimore I drove across
the country I went to Huntington Beach I
literally knew no one and no one knew me
and so I'm sleeping there and then I
realized that I can't really sleep at
night and so I'm I'm taking basically
I'm living on naps for the first six
months of the gym
and like homeless people are sleeping in
my parking lot and I have to like go out
and tell them to like go away and then I
get back lock the door and I go back on
the AstroTurf which is where I slept
with a blanket and a pillow and I I
bring this up because like the visceral
feeling that you go through when you're
going through the mound of period
or the eating what feels like a
marathon
is that it's
it becomes 30 second sound bite in my
story yeah but it was years and so like
even at the same group of like man
you're such a natural salesman the first
job I ever got offered out of college
was a sales job and I said I'm not a
Salesman I'm an academic oh and then as
soon as I opened my gym I was like oh
how do I pay rent and someone
walked in the door and I was like please
give me money uh I promise and I I had
no equipment in my gym because I
couldn't afford any so it's an empty gym
with just Turf and I was like I promise
you I will get you amazing results and
they're like are you gonna be here
tomorrow and I was like I sleep here I
have to be here I promise I'll be here
it's impossible for me to not be here I
can't live I can't leave right and so
the early people took pity on me when
they literally paid the for the first 29
members I signed up in the first two
weeks before the gym opened was from
pity it wasn't from Charisma it was pure
pity I'll be real with you and it was
the exact amount that I needed to pay
rent and I remember the first month of
rent that I paid with this is actually
wild I only I only looked at this in
retrospect
I made exactly four thousand nine
hundred and seventy two dollars in my
first month of my gym my rent was four
thousand nine hundred and seventy two
dollars and I remember working like a
dog to get that I'd never made money in
my life like I never like really asked
anyone for money and all of a sudden I
had to come up five thousand dollars in
a month and then at the end of the month
I watched it go to zero and then I was
like I have to do it again
and that was when like the reality of
the situation of like there was no
Escape there was no one who was going to
come to save me and there was I couldn't
blame my dad I couldn't blame my mom I
was the one who had chosen this life
but the alternative was that I had to go
back to my father of failure and have
him look and look me in the eyes and say
I told you and come here come here don't
worry about it you know I told you this
this gym stuff this Fitness stuff this
starting room it's it's for later it's
fine just go about hey you've got this
you've got this great degree you've got
just go to the go to the business school
to do the thing and I knew exactly what
happened but would have happened after
that
is that for the rest of my life he would
have had absolute authority over
everything that I did and that felt like
death and so that was what I ran away
from when I was in that moment like
whenever I felt like my back was against
the wall and I didn't know what to do
and it felt like the Instagram reels of
like the motivation weren't going to get
me through what I was going through
because no one cared that I was sleeping
alone I let them know I'm sleeping on
the floor and a month later when you're
still sleeping on the floor and
everyone's like don't care like great
you're pursuing your dream right right
early days
but
despite that the must be easy Mantra is
the easiest indicator that you have a
victim mindset
because what it means is I can't achieve
this thing because on some level you say
it must be easy there's some level of
desire that's there you're like I'd like
to achieve some aspect of this and then
rather than feel the pain of saying that
I'm inadequate or I'm not taking action
we cast our our inadequacy on some
outside object or some outside
circumstance and by doing that we remove
all agency and all power that we have
over a lot our lives and for me I would
rather be somebody who has absolute
power and have nothing to show for it
than somebody who has all the all the
the things to show for it but know that
I'm life's
life being one protracted training
montage is a really important lesson to
learn the fact that in the Rocky movie
it is 90 seconds and then everything is
fixed and that can last for decades that
can last for years and I think that
the lack of Glory the lack of certainty
yeah
it makes it it turns it from
worthwhile
Majesty
into
it's it's not even sufficiently
triumphant to be called sad
like it's just like weak and pissy and
you have no idea if anything's gonna
work
but what's the alternative entropy is
going to come and get you so
what's the alternative like my Twitter
bio says locally reversing entropy and I
I think that that really is what you
should try and do because it's going to
come for you the lack of
certainty is what actually makes it
worth it and so here's my point let's
think let's consider the alternative
which is that you are on the path and
you are guaranteed to know that you're
going to get the outcome
all of the mystery is gone there is no
excitement which is why they said you
know in the ancient Romans are sorry the
ancient Greeks would say that the gods
always envied The Mortals because their
life was so ephemeral they had so much
chance that could happen to them right
where the gods always knew that they
weren't going to die and it was
completely guaranteed and so what we do
is we basically have this wish that if
it actually came true we would hate it
even more than our current circumstance
if you knew that you were going to
succeed it wouldn't be worth doing to
begin with the fact that you are
uncertain when you start is what makes
it worthwhile and the fallacy of being
in the pursuit is the worry or the
concern that it won't amount to anything
because who you are becoming is the
thing that you are amounting to in real
time every day
this was something that Mark Manson
tweeted he put it in his newsletter
actually and it made me think of a
lesson that I learned a long time ago
stop complaining about the results you
didn't get from the work you didn't put
in the only way to become more
successful than most people is to be
willing to do something most people
aren't willing to do
and this is that lean in mentality again
take a look
it sucks it's shitty you're tired
everybody says that you're leaving your
friends behind leaving your family
behind betraying your culture betraying
whatever expectation it is that they
have on you
you need to do something that most
people aren't willing to do because as
we've said the average American is obese
in debt and divorced like is that really
oh brilliant fantastic I'm in the
center of the bell curve
distribution here that's really
congratulations and then the other side
stop complaining about the results you
didn't get from the work you didn't put
in okay so you didn't lose weight this
month did you follow your diet well I
did for half the month okay so is it any
surprise that you didn't lose any weight
houses your content creation game going
well I I you know I spent a lot of time
planning for the podcast that I'm going
to release of for the Instagram that I'm
going to start or from the sub stack
that I'm going to begin writing on okay
and what did you actually do it comes
back to like the work
doesn't care yeah
Charlie Munger in one of his seminal
speeches he talks about how to guarantee
failure how to make sure that you are a
failure and he inverts the the concept
of success it's like what could you do
to make sure that you were a failure
it's like well you would definitely get
involved in drugs drinking he says was
it leveraged liquor in women that's you
know the Charlie is Charlie's big one
right
but one of the ones that he has I think
he has seven in his in his in his speech
is
consistency he's like you have to make
sure that you're inconsistent he's like
because
if you are consistent and you have none
of the other attributes he's like it's
you still might be successful he's like
it's it's very tough for people who are
consistent to not be successful and he
makes an especially pointed point about
consistency because in my opinion it's
one of the most difficult of the virtues
for humans to do because we're so
attracted to novelty and so like
I mean I used to deal with this with you
know people on their diets all the time
I remember I ran gems and so someone
would come in and I would always ask a
question so have you been following the
meal plan and then they would say yes
and so then I started changing the way I
asked the question so I'd say out of the
21 meals that you were supposed to eat
how many of the 21 did you have exactly
the way it was on the meal plan and then
they would be like oh I mean at least
half and they would say it as though
that was a mark of success
and right now the meal plan could be
your content plan it could be your it
could be your showing up to work on time
plan it could be the time that you want
to put towards your side hustle doesn't
really matter
but
if there's one muscle that you can Flex
it's learning to do the same thing over
and over again like one of the one of
the values that we had at gym launch is
do the boring work because boring is
what makes you rich right it's it's it's
it's it's writing the follow-up sequence
to your to the purchase page that you
don't feel like doing but you know you
should do it's running the split test
for the 10th time it's it's actually
going through and prepping for 20
minutes before you have the meeting
because
it's amazing how much smarter you can
appear with 20 minutes of preparation
like you can appear 50 IQ points smarter
if you just prepare for meetings for 20
minutes I remember I did a Consulting
day which I've only done three in my
entire life
and when I showed up uh to the day
because I always want to make sure that
everyone always gets more for me than I
than they give me
um I had taken I don't know four hours
not a long time but a long time for I
think some people but for me four hours
is nothing I count in hundreds so this
was irrelevant
and so I took four hours and actually
took the time and put it in to do
research on the individual so I looked
at every single page they had every
landing page every offer every
everything and I had seven pages of
things that I thought would make them
more money
and so when I started I was like this is
what we're going to go through today and
I'll walk you through line by line and
you'll have this as a take behind so you
can execute it with your team it's a
bigger company
and the guy was shocked he was like
never my entire life as anyone had this
preparation and that's what goes back to
like you need 20 podcasts to be in the
top one percent the
the bar for excellence like I have this
timer that I have on my desk which it's
it's the easiest purchase you can make I
think it was like seven bucks on Amazon
it's a little twist kitchen timer it's
very easy and it's been probably my
biggest Focus hack you know to date
which is I turn it when I want to start
working and part of it allows me to
think how long I get better at
predicting how long it's gonna take me
to do something so I think I think this
will take me 35 minutes so I turn the
clock to 35 and I click on and I start
working on the thing and the moment my
phone rings or I look at slack or
whatever I stop the timer and so you
actually see that your time on task is
usually significantly less than you
think it is and I think that
in my early days I would spend a very
long time in front of a computer telling
myself that I was working with very few
minutes actually on task and that's why
I think that most things are actually
significantly easier than people think
they are they just don't know how to try
hard because the harder that you try the
easier it gets and so it's like if you
can just learn to love what trying hard
feels like
then all of a sudden it becomes
unreasonable that you can't win so like
for the presentation that I'm giving I
explained a little bit earlier about
what my process looks like if you were
to say what would it take for somebody
to be unreasonably good that it would be
impossible for them to not be a top one
percent salesman or a top one percent
content creator and he said what would
that person need to do irrelevant from
outcome what would be the actions or
evidence that they would have to do
prior to that thing that would make it
unreasonable that they couldn't succeed
and then you do those things what
happens is you realize that it's
actually not that hard because you put
so much work into it and the bar from
other people working is so
embarrassingly low
that they then ask you how you did it it
must be easy
consistency
doesn't guarantee that you'll be
successful
but not being consistent will guarantee
that you won't reach success you have a
productivity hack an easy productivity
hack instead of spending time getting in
the mood to work just start working
confront the work people think they need
perfect conditions to start when in
reality starting is the perfect
condition
I'm married to that
I love that
because
if you think like I you know I obviously
am somebody who always wants to optimize
how much work I do per unit of time and
so I I was you know there was definitely
times earlier in my life I was really
romanticized by these like very
extensive morning routines and
supplement rituals and like all this
stuff of mental masturbation around the
work that needed to be done but when I
looked at two hours later and nothing
had actually gotten done
the moment you begin working
is when your output per unit of time
goes up
and so that makes beginning the single
greatest hack that you can have for
everything else that you do and work
because things when you start working
you start getting in the mood to work
right like everything else is
procrastinating around the work that you
think you should do but like I have
noticed for me at least I have these I
have some big mental tasks you know what
I mean like big content piece or big
thing that you need like you know it's
going to take real mental effort it
takes me like five minutes of actually
being in it to then get a little bit of
a lay of the land to then get into it
but I used to take hours to delay to
start the first five minutes and so my
time compression of when I thought I
should start doing something and when I
started doing it over time it's just
compressed to the point where it's like
the moment I think that I need to start
doing it sometimes I just start it
because then what happens I get this
open loop and so rather than complete
work at like because a lot of people
were like I want to complete it at this
really nice clean Point stop halfway
through the sentence because it'll drive
you mad that's the zygonic effect in
full work do you know this story
psygonic oh wow this is it's way more
than I do that's why you shut up that's
what you're leveraging here so
um the zygonic effect was a study
originally done on servers in
restaurants okay and they realized
you've ever been at a restaurant and a
server comes up and stands with the
hands behind the back and go what would
you like tonight sir and you say I'll
have the lobster roll and a glass of red
wine and a blah blah and you're like
this motherfucker's not he hasn't got a
pen or a pad of paper he's crazy and
then they go off and what they realized
was servers in restaurants
were unbelievably good at being able to
recall exactly what a table's order was
while that table's order was still open
so uh guys in table 16 they want to swap
the peas out for a little bit of extra
rice and they're doing this thing as
soon as the table was closed they
couldn't remember anything so this is an
open loop closed loop system and it's
built into the brain
the brain abhors an open loop it's the
same reason why Netflix Cliffhangers at
the end of every episode guaranteed that
you'll watch the next one because you
can't bear the fact there's even novels
in the dark romance genre that make
guarantees that there won't be
Cliffhangers they make they put it on
the front or the back of the book and
they say no Cliffhanger is guaranteed
which is
people have so much distaste for it that
it's a selling point that you get the
closure at the end of it and finishing
halfway through a sentence
reduces the activation energy required
to begin that sentence the next day and
it keeps it in your mind too overnight
so I think yeah whether you've stumbled
on it or whether you knew about it
you've managed to leverage a pretty
powerful piece of psychology though sick
going back to the work thing uh another
one from you that I absolutely adore it
just takes work shitloads and shitloads
of work every time I try and dress it up
or cut a corner I get brutally reminded
the work just needs doing the work
doesn't care who you are it just cares
that it gets done
I'm actually going to reverse quote
David Goggins on this one
but uh I love this quote that he has
which he says there's no shortcuts for
you David or there's no shortcuts for
you Goggins I heard him say that and I
just love that as a refrain which is
that a lot of people look for a shortcut
but the idea that you say like they're
not for you you don't get to use them
you are immune to shortcuts
I just love it because then it just
further shortcuts the path to the work
that needs to get done
and I wrote that tweet on my I don't
know 11th run of this presentation that
I'm doing because that's a recent one
yeah and so I was it was like 11 o'clock
at night and so right now I'm working
triple shifts which is not common for me
I usually do two not three
um so for me a normal work day is like I
wake up uh I start working at you know
six or seven and then I go until about
six ish so it's like 10 to 12 really
concentrated of hours work and that I
can do six and a half days a week I
usually take Saturday afternoons off
um and it's really just because at that
point I can't work anymore in My Brain
Stew and then I I get my one half day
and then I'm good to go and I'm rearing
to kick on you know to work on Sundays
my triple shift is I get I go to dinner
and I come back at 7 30 and then I work
from 7 30 until 11 30 or 1 or whatever
right
and when I'm putting in triple shifts is
when I know I'm like really gassing it
um and that's that's what I'm like
repeatedly doing 16 17 a day of actual
productive work and
I I hear the same thoughts that everyone
does which is like it's not gonna matter
like it's fine you've like it's good
enough like I hate that like it it makes
me sick to even say that right because
the thing that I like David Goggins
right he's got like there's no shortcuts
for you I would say the one that I have
two that are like my internal ones one
that is probably the most common is I
will do what is required
and
this work needs doing
and there's just no way around it and
it's just it's just looking at the face
of the work and it's like smiling back
at me like no one else is going to do it
um and like
I love that one like when we're
recording content in the early days
we're doing like 100 shorts every time
we did it and it was direct to camera
and it was the only time I could fit it
in with all the portfolio stuff that
we're doing
and so I was it was always like I will
do what's required and that's been a
really helpful refrain for me when I'm
confronted with especially when you know
what needs to get done and the second
one is
but I'll know
and so like even if it does go well and
even if everyone else says it's great
but I'll know
and it'll then rob me of all of the joy
of all of those moments in that
experience because I'll know that I
could have done better and the thing is
it's like to to quote myself from
earlier like I've never regretted
working harder
ever not once and some people like on
your deathbed you're like no because I
lived every moment of my day doing what
I wanted to do and I remember I had a
boss when I um my first boss after
college
she said this thing I had had a
particularly good weekend and she said
I'm pretty sure happiness is stringing
as many of those days in a row as you
possibly can
and although I hated the job that piece
of advice has actually been probably
what I has been my blueprint for how to
live which is like my birthday looks the
same as my Tuesdays which looks the same
as my Sundays you know what the original
name
pool for this podcast was this is the
only time in history I've done branding
my entire adult life and with club
nights all you're doing is coming up
with Brands
Paradiso oh it's it's tropical there'll
be a flamingo a skint oh it's a cheap
night it's for people to get fingered in
the corner like it's we all I did was
branding right I was a branding guy I'm
pretty good at copywriting all I did was
running
the one time I've had divine inspiration
three in the morning wake up with the
name was Modern wisdom the one time out
of every business every night every
brand I've ever come up with that was
the one time but on the list of the
others mind mind and matter was one of
them the other one was a quote from Tim
Ferriss it's called crushing a Tuesday
and he said that what you should aim for
in life is for your average Tuesday
not the spectacular one-time private jet
with the friends to go for the whatever
whatever not the UFC power slap launch
party
staring at the back of Dan bilzerian's
dirty mullet like
not that you want your average Tuesday
to look the way that you want most of
your life to do
and when I think about the days that I
look back on at the end of my day and
think like today was a good day
invariably it's the same few things it's
I worked very hard on something that I
felt was worth doing
I worked out and I spent time with
people that I enjoy being around
if I do those three things I had a good
day and so that's been my you know Alex
a simple blueprint for doing things and
I think the point that you were making
earlier I think it's worth hitting on
again which is just that like
most people's definition of work is a
negative one which is why they abhor it
which is also why they misunderstand so
many people who quote I'll say quote
here are successful or ahead of them or
whatever is that both people one person
says the word work and the other person
hears the word pain
and so
the first step to like becoming more
successful is understanding the language
that the people who are successful are
using they're actually defining the word
differently and so
whatever that thing is that you actually
enjoy doing where you lose track of time
when you're in it even if it's
challenging but usually it is
challenging right like it's not easy
because then it's boring right which is
also why the uncertainty thing is so key
right to not knowing if it's gonna if
it's gonna work or not you are going to
work though either way
um
is that the people who are quote
addicted to work make it easy to be
addicted to work because they
do things worth doing
and I think a lot of it is coming down
to making sure that you take the few
precious seconds that we have to do the
few things that are worth doing for the
rest of your life
the more I listen to this the better my
life gets if they don't have what you
want don't listen to what they say
there's no greater waste of time than
justifying your actions to people who
have a life you don't want
that was a message to my younger self
but
um I remember I got it in well I won't I
won't call it out
um
let me see how I can say this the right
way
um
you know what I'll just say it I'll
whitewash the names so I was with a
family member and we were all around the
kitchen table and starting the holidays
because I don't go home very much and
they kind of started attacking me
um and they're like
I would never live your life
you're so unbalanced like attacking and
I was like
what are you saying
and
she said
I I just would never do that and I was
like all right well what part of my life
is unbalanced I was like do you feel
like my health is unbalanced I was like
do you feel like my marriage is
unbalanced I was like do you feel like
my finances are unbalanced I was like
what part of my life do you feel like is
out of whack
she was like you know I'm not as good as
with words as you are and that was the
and I was like okay so the fact that you
can't make a logical argument I'm not
going to continue how that conversation
went but
the the tldr of that was I really
thought a lot about it
and it came down to
I wouldn't live your life
and my response to that is good don't
it's not your life it's mine live yours
the way you want and I wouldn't live
your life either and so what ends up
happening is they become these
statements these projections that are
not actually real
now on some level maybe they were saying
that because there was Envy in that
aspect of like wishing that was there
you know that they were living that life
but in this particular instance I don't
think it was I think they genuinely were
trying to help it was a family member
and they thought they were that I was
being misguided this is an intervention
let me hold the talking pillow Alex
we've all come together because we care
about you we really feel like we need to
have a conversation here it's it's
exactly what it was and I got so angry
you
so angry no and you know you can hear
Layla like patting my back like it's I'm
like see you can feel the heat coming
off of me it's like I'd go upstairs
how dare she you know but it really just
came down to like her just saying I
don't want to live your life and I think
the answer to that question is good
don't and I think that has been one of
the things that has diffused so many of
these like hateful comments where people
dehumanize you or whatever and make you
into this idea that they reject it's
like you're right one of the things that
uh I had a mentor told me to say is like
when you're in an art if somebody's like
it's like you're you're a terrible
person blah blah blah you just say
you're right
and
and then they have no they have they
have nothing to say and then you just
move on with your life and so like in
that way it's acceptance but of like
your
your idea of who I am that you hate so
much I accept it I can live with that
even but like we don't want to think
what if I haven't I don't believe that
but I can do that and I can end the
conversation so I'm taking improv
classes at the moment because I'm doing
my first live shows in the UK and
Ireland oh so this live talk uh thank
you yeah uh everything exists uh no solo
stood on stage for 90 minutes comedy
insights and stuff probably some
that I've learned today uh anyway we
released it and every show sold out and
then got venue upgraded and then sold
out again in less than 45 minutes across
all of the dates which was great but
then scary because I now had to speak to
like three times as many people per
night for additional nights on top of
what I thought anyway
I'm doing improv in improv there is one
rule and the rule is don't punk the game
so uh we're doing some exercise where we
need to make silly noises as we pass
this imaginary energy around and I need
to go like Boeing and send it back and
you need to go whoosh and pass it on and
all this sort of the one thing that
you're not allowed to do
is not make one of the noises that's
allowed yeah
and I really think about punking the
game an awful lot and you see it happen
in podcasts you see it happen on TV you
see it happen and it can be both
destructive and constructive but it's
always destructive to the people that
are trying to play the game and it can
sometimes be constructive to the person
who is punking it so what you did is you
punked the game that
we are playing a game of tennis we are
hitting the ball back and forth here I
go I hit the ball across the net and
oh where is it is it hit it back hit it
hit it back to me yeah like this is the
game that we're playing and you didn't
move reciprocally back and forth you
went orthogonally you went across on a
different axis and you're like I'm not
playing this anymore this is a different
game I'm not bothered
there's not even words to describe what
that means now the way that it can be
destructive is especially if you're
having
let's say a meaningful conversation
sometimes people who are uncomfortable
with getting into their emotions can use
a variety of different things they can
be scathing they can be mocking they can
laugh you know because they don't want
to sit with the discomfort of this
particular part of the conversation
that's punking the game in a way that I
think is destructive both externally and
internally that was one that was
destructive externally it broke the game
but it was constructive internally and
it is a way
refusing to play by the rules that
somebody else has set in a game that you
didn't agree to is the best prophylactic
against stepping into a situation that
you do not want and it's one of the
things that wealth affords
and it's one of the things that freedom
affords and freedom is often Downstream
from wealth remember George one of my
really good friends being on the show
like five times George Mac you'll follow
him on Twitter he's phenomenal
he was on Fox and Friends yesterday
talking about his cocaine phone and his
kale phone like what the what world
is this yeah
I remember
before the first time that I moved away
to work I've been I've traveled a lot
but it was always in between work I
never traveled to work
covet happens
world gets shut down
just after Halloween Boris tells all of
the UK
we're going back into lockdown in three
days time and all flights are canceled
so I messaged George and I was like
I'm not doing this I'm I let's go
somewhere he wanted to go to
I can't I can't even remember some
Island that has 300 000 people on it and
I was like why don't we do Dubai it's a
five hour flight the weather's great I
know people it'll be fun
it's not got 300 000 people on it it'll
be the zuba
and I'll never forget what he
replied to me with I got up and I paid
350 pounds for my covid fit to fly test
before he was awake but he'd sent me a
message the night before and this is
what compelled me to do he said what's
the point in having you Freedom if
you never say you
and I was like
I was so fired up reading that message
and I was like yeah why have I put all
of this work in why have I done all of
these things if I don't ever Punk a game
that I didn't agree to be a part of
I think this is really big if we go all
the way back to the earlier part of this
podcast when you have the friends who
are telling you oh um must be nice or
you think you're better than us or oh so
we can't drink anymore that's when you
be like yeah
then what well then we wouldn't be
friends you're not going to be friends
with them eventually anyways I promise
you anyone who says that so you're not
gonna be friends with if you want to
ultimately become the person you want to
become they're only going to reject you
harder and harder until eventually you
have nothing to share about and the only
thing that you'll talk about is the past
which by the way one of the great
leading indicators of at least in my
opinion of a great way to know when to
cut a friend is when they only talk
about your past
and so punking the game and it's it's
one of those really uncomfortable things
the first time you do it but then you
get more and more comfortable with it
because they're like
I would never live your life and you're
like I know
this relates to another one of yours
don't trade your self-respect for
someone else's it's easy to lose theirs
and hard to get yours back yeah
but I would know but you would know yeah
uh related to the sort of cynicism thing
that we were talking about earlier on I
call it the cynicism safety blanket that
sour grapes at an existential level
um
you've been on my first million uh he
casually drop this I don't think this I
don't think his episode's going to be
out before this goes um but it's money
and he said the cynics get to be right
and the optimists get to be rich
and from you I think the Winner's
mindset sits in the uncomfortable place
between two surface level contradictions
extreme paranoia in the present and
unshakable faith in the future the
tension between the two makes someone
hard to beat today and hard to outlast
tomorrow the cynics get to be right and
the optimists get to be rich
one of the biggest fallacies of the
advice from people who are in your
current situation is that they are right
most of the time when you bring a girl
home
99 times out of 100 when your parents
say she's not the girl I don't like her
she won't last
they're right every single time except
for the one time it matters and you end
up marrying the person right like when
they say like you're not going to
succeed like this idea of yours it's not
going to last and they're right every
single time except for the one time that
matters when you hit it big and so it's
one of those things where
they are right more times but they are
not more ripe
so good
yeah I am
I wonder whether it's a function of
all of our opinions being permanently
etched in stone on social media that
it's very easy to seem smart to have a
heterodox idea if you go against the
mainstream
because it's romantic oh I I I I had
this alternative I I had this negative
I'm not I'm not like one of those sheep
I'll I'll believe that things are going
to be worse than they are and then if it
turns out better guess what I say your
expectations super low congratulations
you can thank me later you're like
that is
distilled down
British culture at its worst yeah is low
expectations
low expectations delivered through
satirical cynicism yeah why are you
doing that that's lame that's for losers
that's something that we wouldn't do you
should stop doing the different thing
tall poppy you're the one that gets cut
down and
it's all that it's like all it shows to
me now
is a kind of group thing
almost like
the worst kind of
mental telepathy where everybody
believes the most unuseful thoughts that
everybody else has yeah
at scale
and all it does is lower the bar
that you need to get up
I think it's that that you're right
thing which is someone says that's lame
that sucks blah blah and you say like
you're right it does
you just keep punking the game like when
anyone comes to try and like like
they're they're playing a different game
than you so you shouldn't try and play
by their rules because they're going to
try and get you to play their game so
that they can beat you at the game which
is the status game of that little circle
but you're playing a much wider game
that includes more players and so even
though locally you have these your your
incoming information that you're taking
in is disproportionate with your people
that you're not actually playing against
and so it's basically just noise it's
irrelevant because if you look on a long
enough time Horizon the likely that
you're act like I mean again I think
about death a lot but
the the idea that
when I die
people will be dividing up my assets
arguing over who gets what there's going
to be a caterer at my funeral some
people won't make it because
something came up
and they got busy
and then the few people that are there
are probably no one that I have in my
life right now and the fact that every
single person that I have in my life
might not even make it to the funeral to
speak over me while I'm dead
it's like why on Earth would I listen to
them while I'm alive
like they can't even make it to probably
the single most important in you know
personal day of someone's life is
someone's funeral right the one time you
can pay your last respect and they don't
even do that and so it's like why would
I give any weight to what these people
are doing when they're not even going to
be there on the day that matters most
and six months later they're not even
remember who I was and anybody who's had
a death in their family recently knows
that in the moment it's terrible for you
and then six months later life moves on
but the thing is is that we just never
paint ourselves as the person who dies
but to me that's incredibly freeing
because then it's like
if six months after I'm dead no one is
going to say my name no one is going to
remember what I did
then No One's Gonna then it doesn't
matter what I do today and I think that
some people see it as really hopeless
but I see it as very hopeful because it
means we have absolute freedom and we
can do crazy like why have you
money if you can't say you
yeah learning isn't a spectator sport it
comes from doing which means if you're
not doing the stuff you consume every
day you're not learning you're just
procrastinating oh this is fine all
right so I'm going to Define some terms
learning
let me say this way
intelligence means rate of learning like
that's what that's how remember I talk
about operationalizing words so rate of
learning is intelligence so then you
which means it's a rate not a not an
attribute as an aside which then means
you have to Define learning learning
means same condition new Behavior so if
I hold up a red card and then I slap you
and then I'll hope a red card again and
then you duck you've learned if you wake
up every day and life shows you a red
card and then you don't duck and you
don't change then you have learned
nothing and so if you go to a weekend
and you go to a workshop and then the
next day you go back and you do the
exact same activities
in the same conditions and you have no
new Behavior it means you learned
nothing it also means you're stupid
because it means your rate of learning
is slow
so if someone is intelligent I can show
them the red card and on the first go
they change their behavior and so by
defining intelligence that way and
defining learning that way it allowed me
to start thinking well I want to be
smart and this circumstance had this
outcome last time and so the next time I
see this circumstance this red card I'm
going to change my behavior and so when
we consume the information that you have
on this podcast or whatever it is
there's probably a circumstance whether
it's a conversation that you're supposed
to have but you aren't having it's a
decision that you need to make but
you're putting off
that's the red card it comes up again
and the question is whether you're going
to get slaps or you're going to duck
and that's where you know whether you
learned or not and every time you get
shown the red card and you do the same
exact thing you just prove to yourself
that your rate of learning is slower and
so for me I want to have that evidence
that I learn quickly and for me that's
why like people see me as ruthless as
you said because I'm willing to cut
relationships because if I think that
I'm going to eventually cut the
relationship
then why would I not cut it today
because I might as well start enjoying
the benefits of cutting that
relationship as soon as humanly possible
Alexa MOSI ladies and gentlemen dude I
love you to bits I genuinely do uh I I
think the work that you put out the
messages that you put out are very very
needed and yeah I could do this for days
we could run this back
literally for days and days and days so
uh this is going to go out after your
big event where should people go to
support you to learn more about the
that you do and and what have you got
coming up well I've got my uh my next
book 100 million dollar leads uh the
first book is 100 million dollar offers
what's interesting question what should
I sell so a lot of people are like what
should I sell it tells you step by step
everything you do like worksheets I have
a free course that goes with it you
don't even have to opt in it's on my
site acquisition.com you can just start
watching it
um I think the Kindle for offers is 1.99
like try to make I mean our mission is
to make real business education
accessible for everyone
um 100 leads has been six hours a day 6
a.m to 12 uh 12 P.M every day for the
last two years so the first six hours of
every day has been dedicated to writing
that book which is why I have 19 drafts
four four four full rewrites there's 106
hand-drawn images
um that went in the book that I put in
there
um and I'm going to be releasing it at
this event that Chris and I were talking
about
um so you're gonna be listening to this
after that event
um and so you can go on Amazon it'll be
available there or you can look at
acquisition.com because they'll be a
course and things that you can go
through free materials and that the the
100 million dollar leads answers the
question who do I sell it to and so you
need leads right so you're like okay
great I have the thing I'm gonna sell
who how do I go get people to find out
about it and so a lot of the things that
I have in the book are defining some of
the terms that people hear a lot which
is like what is a lead what is
advertising right advertising is the
process of making known and so if no one
knows about your stuff no one can buy it
and so the reverse of that is everyone
knows about your stuff and that book
will show you how to get everyone to
know about your stuff and the reason I
made the event as big as I did was
because I used every advertising method
in the book to advertise the book itself
so offers was an example of a grand slam
offers how do you make something so good
everyone feels stupid saying no which is
the sub headline of the book
and so offers in and of itself was a
grand slam offer which is what I argue
that everyone should have it was a two
dollar book that it comes with a course
it comes with worksheets all these
things and 100 leads the way that I
wanted to exemplify and meta show
demonstrate that the concept of the book
work today and will work tomorrow and
will work in 100 years is because humans
haven't changed and so the process of
making known Remains the Same because
our hard wiring is the same so you don't
need to know the Instagram hack because
my first ever advertisement was on
Facebook and I don't do anything on
Facebook now and it doesn't matter and
as soon as YouTube and podcasts and all
those things die
the principles remain the same despite
the platforms changing and so that is
what I wrote each of these books because
I want them to be around in 100 years
and that's why I spent so long on them
um but I'm very proud of the book and I
think it's my best work to date
Alex I appreciate you thank you man
thank you
oh hey if you enjoyed that episode with
Alex homozy then press here for the one
that we did six months ago which goes
for a full another two hours
go on
press it
foreign